ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
POWER QUE HAN.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER FOR BATH
[inaudible]
BONTA BRO [inaudible]
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM DALY.
DAILY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA.
GONZALEZ IS.
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LEVINE LIMON.
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
[inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
AS PART OF THE ASSEMBLY'S
OBSERVANCE OF API HERITAGE MONTH.
DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THERE ARE OVER FORTY COUNTRIES
AND CULTURES IN THE PACIFIC.
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLAND AREA.
THEIR CULTURAL INFLUENCE ON THE
WORLD STAGE NOW A NATURAL PART
OF OUR EVERYDAY LIFE.
IN THE AREAS OF ART MUSIC DANCE
LITERATURE FOOD PHILOSOPHY
SPIRITUALITY SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
POLITICS.
IN EVERY DIMENSION OF OUR LIVES
WE HAVE A FUSION OF CULTURAL
CLEAVERS.
AND IT IS WONDERFUL.
IT IS BOTH BEAUTIFUL AND
MEANINGFUL TO TAKE PRIDE IN THE
CULTURES AND TRADITIONS WITHIN
WHICH WE HAVE BEEN ROUTED.
EVEN MORE BEAUTIFUL IS IT TO
TAKE PRIDE IN THE MULTI CULTURAL
HERITAGE THAT IN ESSENCE WE ALL
SHARE.
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND MOST ESPECIALLY IN
BEING A PART THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH THERE ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED COUNTRIES RECOGNIZED BY
THE UNITED NATIONS IN THE WORLD
TODAY.
WE ARE NOT SEPARATE.
WE ALL ALL ONE HUMANITY IN THE
BORDER THIS GEOGRAPHY OF THE
EARTH.
IN HAVING A ONE WORLD VISION.
WE WILL BEGIN TO LIVE WITH AN
EVER DEEPENING EMPATHY.
AND AN EVER GROWING KINDNESS AS
WE EMBRACE AND APPRECIATE.
THE DIVERSITY AND BEAUTY OF OUR
SHARED HUMANITY.
NOW MORE MEET UP.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER FALL.
A SALUTE PLEASURE.
I'D LIKE. TO SEE THE OF THE
AMERICAN -- THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY NINETEEN RECENTLY
MET AT NINE AM ON OVER BACK UP
OUR QUE HAN ASSISTANT SPEAKER
PRO TEM OF THIS FAMILY PRESIDING
CHEAPER KEY DOTSON WILSON AT THE
DESK.
ASSISTANT CLICK DAVID ABLEMAN
READING THE ROLES CALLED THE
MEMBER COLDER MOVED TO CONTROL
THE ASSEMBLY MOTION TIME MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS.
THAT THE PREVIOUS THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AUTUMN BURKE.
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BILL BRO.
AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS DAVID CHIU AND SALAS TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SHOES GUESTS WILL
BE IN THE AREA THE MEMBERS DESK.
FOR THE API HERITAGE CEREMONY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH A WITH
YOUR THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE FOUR POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER TO SPEAK.
ON A GERMAN A MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT WILL SIX TO EIGHT FILE
NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO MEET
THIS WEDNESDAY MAY FIFTEENTH AT
NINE AM.
AND ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO TO
HEAR BILLS CURRENTLY LISTED ON
THE REGULAR ORDER OF BUSINESS
AGENDA FOR THURSDAY MAY
SIXTEENTH.
I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND JOINT WILL SIXTY TWO
A TO FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE
TO HEAR AB TEN FIFTY FOUR HOLDEN
ON WEDNESDAY MAY FIFTEENTH.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
LOWER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE ITEM ONE
FOURTEEN AB ELEVEN THIRTY TO
GABRIEL FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
EVER SINCE ONE OF RECOGNIZE THAT
WE HAVE A FORMER MEMBER OF THIS
HOUSE AS WELL AS THE STATE
SENATE WHO JOIN US ON THE FLOOR
TODAY THE HONORABLE KEVIN MURRAY.
WELCOME BACK SIR
.
MEMBERS A VERY QUICK
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE BOW TIE CAUCUS
YES THERE IS A BOW TIE CAUCUS.
THERE WILL BE A PHOTO -- IN THE
WELL HERE ARE RIGHT UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION THEY'LL
BE A PHOTO.
ON THE FLOOR OF THE BOW TIE
CAUCUS UPON A GERMAN
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS IN
THE CHAMBER TODAY MEMBERS.
MR LEVINE YOU HAVE GUESTS WITH
US TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING THIRTY ONE FIFTH
GRADERS FROM TO BROWN SEEN
HILLARY SCHOOL THERE RIGHT UP
HERE VISITING TAKE THAT TORE.
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH FOR
COMING UP AND CHECK IT OUT STATE
GOVERNMENT.
AND MR SALAS.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GAS
INTRODUCTION MR SALAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT THE C.
R. TWENTY NINE IS YOUR IS YOUR
SALAS.
THIS IS A SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
GUESTS FROM THE WEST WEST HILL
COLLEGE.
WHO JOINED US?
OKAY WE HAVE.
GUESTS FIRST TAKE IT FROM ME
THEY'RE HERE.
THIS IS WEST HILL COLLEGE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MR
SALAS -- WITHOUT OBJECTION
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM NINETY NINE
WHICH IS YOUR ITEM MISTER SALAS
THIS IS FILE ITEM [inaudible]
NINETY NINE ALL RIGHT.
HOLD ONE MOMENT OF SILENCE.
MR SALAS BEFORE WE TAKE OF YOUR
ITEM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IS BUSY
DAY HERE IN THE CAPITAL --
PLEASE MEMBERS WELCOME THE WEST
HILLS COLLEGE STUDENTS WERE UP
IN THE GALLERY THIS MORNING WITH
US JOINING US -- TODAY FROM THE
BALLOT SO JOIN ME IN ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR THEM.
AND NOW MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO TAKE UP.
MR SALAS SAYS ITEM ON THE FILE
WHICH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINETY NINE AC ARE TWENTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS RELATIVE TO BLUE STAR
MOTHERS OF AMERICA MONTH.
MR SALAS YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IS A
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ACR TWENTY NINE WHICH RECOGNIZES
MAY.
TWENTY NINETEEN AS BLUESTAR
MOTHER'S OF AMERICA MONTH THE
REFERENCE TO THE BLUE STAR DATES
BACK TO WORLD WAR.
ONE WHEN MILITARY FAMILIES WOULD
HANG A SERVICE FLAG IN THEIR
WINDOWS.
A BLUE STAR BECAME THE
UNOFFICIAL SYMBOL OF A CHILD AND
SERVICE BLUESTAR MOTHERS ARE THE
LARGEST AND FASTEST GROWING
MILITARY ORGANIZATION.
IN THE COUNTRY THE AND AS
INSPIRED MORE THAN TWENTY SIX
MILLION HOURS OF VOLUNTEER
SERVICE STATION WIDE MEMBERS I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THESE BLUE
STAR FAMILIES OR PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMPLETELY DEDICATED TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THEY SEND CARE PACKAGES OVERSEAS
THEY'RE INVOLVED N A NUMBER OF
LOCAL EVENTS WHETHER IT'S A
MILITARY RELATED OR NOT.
TODAY WE'RE JOINED BY A NUMBER
OF MILITARY FAMILIES A NUMBER OF
LOOSE OUR FAMILIES.
AND MEMBERS IF YOU HAVE NOT
REACHED OUT TO YOUR LOCAL
CHAPTER PLEASE SEE ME I'M MORE
THAN HAPPY TO GET YOU CONNECTED
TO YOUR LOCAL CHAPTERS.
BECAUSE THESE MOTHERS EXIST UP
AND DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WOULD LOVE FOR
YOU TO BE A PART OF THEIR
ORGANIZATION WHAT THEY DO FOR A
COMMUNITY AND FOR OUR FAMILIES --
CURRENTLY SERVING SO WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND IF WE CAN OPEN THE ROLL
CALL AUTHORS AND CREATE THAT AS
WELL.
THANK YOU MISS SHOWERS SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
RESOLUTION MR SALAS IS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS CARPAL OF THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON A HERE TWENTY NINE THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ADDING ON
THE RESOLUTION [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SIXTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MISTER SALAS.
RETURNING TO YOU FOR YOUR
SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION
RELATIVE TO THIS RESOLUTION
MISTER SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS IF YOU CAN PLEASE JOIN
ME.
IN WELCOMING OUR BLUE STAR
MOTHERS WE HAVE AT LEAST TWENTY
BLUESTAR MOTHERS HERE FROM.
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SOME FROM THE VALLEY FROM FROM A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE MEMBERS LET'S GIVE THEM A
HUGE ROUND OF APPLAUSE A WELCOME
THEM TO THIS LEGISLATION
.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OUR SPECIAL
CEREMONY IN HONOR OF ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN.
HERITAGE MONTH.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE
TO FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE A. C. R..
SEVENTY FOUR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THIRD.
READING MISTER KALRA ARE YOU
READY TO PROCEED.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ACR.
SEVENTY FOUR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY FOUR BY
FAMILY MEMBER KALRA AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO ASIAN OR PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
WAS THE CAR YOU MAY OPEN ON A C.
R..
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT ACR.
SEVENTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS TO RECOGNIZE
MAY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AS
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH.
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO OVER SIX
POINT THREE MILLION ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICANS THE
LARGEST POPULATION.
IN THE COUNTRY.
MOREOVER ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICANS ARE ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING AT THE POPULATIONS IN
THE STATE.
AND NATION.
FROM CHINESE LABORERS WHO CAME
IN THE MID TO LATE EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS TO WORK THE GOLD MINES
AND HELP BUILD THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD. TO
SOUTH ASIANS TO IMMIGRATE TO
WORK IN THE WEST GROWING
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY DURING THE
LATE EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS. TO THE
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT PROGRAMS
THAT BROUGHT MUCH OF OUR
SOUTHEAST ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY TO CALIFORNIA IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
API HISTORY IS INCREDIBLY
DIVERSE AND BY APPARENTLY RICH.
WALL API COMMUNITIES SOUGHT
REFUGE OR IMMIGRATED HERE DURING
DIFFERENT TIME PERIODS.
THE CHALLENGES THEY FACE IN THE
UNITED STATES WERE SIMILAR.
MANY OF WHICH STEMMED FROM
POLICIES ENACTED BY LAWMAKERS
DURING THAT TIME.
THE CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT OF
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO PROHIBITED
CHINESE LABORS FROM ENTERING
THIS COUNTRY.
AT A LATER AMENDMENT IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR EXPANDED THIS LAW
AND BARRED ALL INDIVIDUALS FROM
ALL ASIAN COUNTRIES.
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN HUNDREDS
XENA PHOBIC ALIEN LAND LAWS
PREVENTED CHINESE INDIAN
JAPANESE AND KOREAN FARMERS FROM
OWNING FARMS.
IN CALIFORNIA.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTEEN THE U. S.
CONGRESS ADOPTED THE NINETEEN
SEVENTEEN IMMIGRATION ACT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE ASIATIC
BARRED ZONE ACT.
WHICH PROHIBITED MANY FOR THE
ENTIRETY OF THE INDIAN
SUBCONTINENT.
FROM IMMIGRATING. TO THE UNITED
STATES.
THESE EXAMPLES FROM OUR SHARED
HISTORY ARE IMPORTANT IN
UNDERSTANDING HOW IT HAS SHAPED
OUR ASIAN AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITIES TODAY.
AND IS SERVED AS A REMINDER OF
THE NEED FOR DIVERSITY WITHIN
OUR LEGISLATIVE BODIES.
IN RESPONSE TO THESE CHALLENGES.
API A COMMUNITIES DEVELOP THEIR
OWN SERVICES IN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND AT THE
COMMUNITIES LIKE LITTLE SAIGON
IN SAN JOSE AND MOST RESULT MOST
RECENTLY IN SAN DIEGO.
THEY ORGANIZE FILIPINO AMERICAN
FARMWORKERS WHO FOUGHT FOR
WORKERS RIGHTS AS PART OF THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES.
THEY ALSO DEDICATED THEMSELVES
TO FIGHTING FOR THERE'S FOR THIS
COUNTRY THEIR HOME.
JAPANESE AMERICANS FOUGHT
BRAVELY FOR OUR COUNTRY DURING
WORLD WAR.
TWO WHILETHEIR FAMILIES WERE IN
IN IN INTERMENT CAMPS BACK HOME.
NOT ONLY DID THEY FIGHT FOR THIS
COUNTRY BUT THEY BECAME ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN DOLLARS
SING SONG FROM CALIFORNIA.
WAS ELECTED TO CONGRESS I WAS
THE FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN INDIAN
AMERICAN AND SICK AMERICAN. TO
SERVE AS A CONGRESS MEMBER.
IN THE UNITED STATES.
TODAY THERE'S A RECORD HIGH OF
TWENTY API'S SERVING IN CONGRESS.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY ONE ALPERS
SONG WAS THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN ELECTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA ALLEGED.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY ONE I'LL PER
SONG WAS THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN ELECTED. TO THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
TODAY WE HAVE SIXTEEN WITH A
RECORD NUMBER OF FOURTEEN
SERVING IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
AND TODAY I AM PROUD TO BE ONE
OF THE ASIAN AMERICANS ELECTED.
TO THIS STORY BODY AS THE FIRST
INDIAN AMERICAN TO SERVE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
CELEBRATING ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER HERITAGE MONTH PROVIDES
CALIFORNIANS WITH AN OPPORTUNITY
TO RECOGNIZE THE ACHIEVEMENTS
CONTRIBUTIONS AND HISTORY.
OF ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICANS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN COMMEMORATING
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH BY SUPPORTING ACR.
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA MISTER CHOI.
YOUR RECOGNIZED ME TO ASK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY.
I STAND TODAY IN SUPPORT OF A
ACR SEVENTY FOUR CELEBRATING Vì
ã SON HERITAGE MON.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECT IS SHARP
RESOLUTION AND THE SPIRIT IN
WHICH IT IS A BROUGHT TO WITH
THIS SO CHAMBER.
A BY THE WAY -- MISS ARE FOR THE
SONG.
WAS SO THE FIRST OR ASIAN
AMERICAN [inaudible]
ALL.
WHO BROKE THE BARRIER OUGHT TO
SERVE ON THIS SAW A LEGISLATURE --
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE AND WE
ALSO ALL PROBLEMS.
A DOCTOR HE WAS SO ALSO KOREAN
AMERICAN.
AT THIS RESOLUTION UNIFIES SO I
WAS STATE IN CELEBRATING OUR
DIVERSE CITY.
IT IS SO THROUGH THE VAST.
DIVERSE THE OF A CALIFORNIA.
FULL OF A MANY PEOPLE OF A
DIVERSE A CULTURES AND
BACKGROUNDS.
NOT THAT WE FIND DOES SUCH A
STRENGTH.
THIS IS A RESOLUTION RECOGNIZING
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS SAW
CULTURES BRINGS THEM MANY PEOPLE
OF THE PACIFIC OCEAN RING TO
GATHER IN RECOGNITION OF DO
CONTRIBUTIONS UP TO A CALIFORNIA --
READING THE TELL THE PACIFIC
OCEAN RING.
IS THE OP POSITIVE A SYMBOL OF
OUR UNITY AND THE STRENGTH. FOR
OUR STATE.
IT IS OF THE RADIO RECOGNIZING.
EACH OF THOSE SUBCULTURES AND
THE BACKGROUNDS THAT BUT WE
LEARNED -- TO EXCEPT IS JOE
THOUGH AND THE LIVE TOGETHER AS
SOMEONE COMMUNITY.
I BELIEVE THAT THE OUR WORK.
IN THIS BUILDING ALL SHOULD BE
ARE CENTERED.
ON THIS A STYLE OF OUR UNITY AND
UPBRINGING THE DIVERS TO
CULTURES ALL OF THIS A STATE
TOGETHER.
I AND THE GIRL TO GET THE AS
SOMEONE FAMILY.
IT IS SO FOR THOSE REASONS SO
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK OF FOR
YOUR I'VE WILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOI MR HOLDEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR
DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
IN HONOR OF ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
THE ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IS VIBRANT.
AND VITAL PART OF CALIFORNIA.
LAST FRIDAY THE COUNTRY
CELEBRATED THE HUNDRED FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD
A TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
TRIUMPH THAT REVOLUTIONIZED
AMERICAN TRAVEL AND ECONOMY.
SUCH AN ADVANCEMENT IN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
COULD NOT HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE
WITHOUT THE TOILET CHINESE
AMERICAN IMMIGRANTS.
AND PURSUE THE AMERICAN DREAM
MEN AND WOMEN LABORED UNDER A
BOARD WORKING CONDITIONS FOR
LITTLE OR NO PAY AND WERE
SUBJECT TO THE ON REAL AND
RACISM.
THAT IS WOVEN INTO THE AMERICAN
CULTURAL LANDSCAPE.
LIKE MANY AMERICANS ARE CAUGHT
LIKE MANY OF AMERICA'S
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
THE RAILROAD FROM SEA TO SHINING
SEA WAS BUILT ON THE BLOOD SWEAT
AND TEARS AND SOMETIMES
LITERALLY THE BACKS.
OF COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
WE ON THIS MOVEMENT IN HISTORY.
MEMBERS OF THE API COMMUNITY
HAVE CONTRIBUTED GREATLY TO THIS
COUNTRY THROUGH ACTIVISM.
LITERATURE INNOVATION.
MUSIC ACADEMIA AND POLITICS.
AND I SEE MEMBERS OF THE API
CAUCUS FIGHT FOR THE WELL BEING
AND JUST TREATMENT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS EVERY DAY.
I THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
SAN JOSE.
OR FOR GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
COMMEMORATION I ASK YOU ALLTO
COMMEMORATE THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
THE API COMMUNITY.
HAS HAD ON OUR COUNTRY AND VOTE
IN FAVOR.
OF A C. R..
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
HOLDEN.
MR GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FROM YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
THIS AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS IN SUPPORTED AC ARE.
SEVENTY FOUR LATINOS HAVE HAD A
LONG.
HISTORY IN COMMUNITY AND
COALITION BUILDING WITH OUR
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
COMMUNITY.
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN HUNDREDS
IMMIGRATION RESTRICTIONS AND
XENA PHOBIC LAND OWNERSHIP LAWS
BROUGHT TOGETHER -- TO JABI AND
MEXICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO FORM COLLECTIVE
FARMING COMMUNITIES IN THE
CENTRAL IMPERIAL VALLEY'S OF OUR
GREAT STATE.
DURING THE FAMOUS FIVE YEAR TO
LINE OF GRAPE STRIKE IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES CESAR CHAVEZ
AND LOS WHERE TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH FILIPINOS THE BILL OF
VERACRUZ AND LET IT LONG. TO
FIGHT FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
WORKER RIGHTS UNDER THE
HISTORIES AND OUR HISTORY
STRONGEST MULTI ETHNIC ALLIANCE
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS.
MEMBERS THERE ARE MANY MANY
EXAMPLES IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY
OF THE API COMMUNITY AND THE
LATINO COMMUNITY BANDED TOGETHER
FOR THE IMPROVEMENT OF OUR STATE.
WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
FACT CAUCUS THIS AFTERNOON AND
ASK RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON ACR SEVENTY FOUR THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA.
MISS POWER QUE HAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR.
SEVENTY FOUR THIS RESOLUTION
PROVIDES CALIFORNIANS WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE THE
ACHIEVEMENTS CONTRIBUTIONS IN
HISTORY OF ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICANS.
THE API COMMUNITIES HAD
EXTENSIVE INFLUENCE ON
CALIFORNIA'S CULTURE AND ECONOMY.
THE TRADITIONS HISTORY KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPERIENCES ARE ESSENTIAL TO
THE PROSPERITY AND CHARACTER OF
OUR STATE.
WE CELEBRATE API HERITAGE MONTH
IN MAY BECAUSE TWO IMPORTANT
ANNIVERSARIES OCCURRED DURING
THIS TIME.
THE ARRIVAL OF THE FIRST
JAPANESE AMERICANS.
IMMIGRANTS IN AMERICA ON MAY
SEVENTH EIGHTEEN FORTY THREE AND
THE COMPLETION OF THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD ON MAY
TENTH.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE THE MAJORITY
OF THE WORKERS WHO LAID THE
TRACKS WERE CHINESE IMMIGRANTS
WHO ARE TREATED EXTREMELY POORLY.
THEY INDOOR THESE HARDSHIPS IN
CASUALTIES AND DESPITE THE
DEDICATED LABOR OF THESE
IMMIGRANTS THE HELP TO BUILD OUR
STATE AND OUR COUNTRY.
AMERICA WAS NOT ALWAYS WELCOMING
THE JEWISH LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
STANDS WITH IMMIGRANTS TODAY IN
OUR HISTORY WHO'VE BEEN TREATED
IN THIS FASHION.
NO MATTER THE ROAD BLOCKS THE
API COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A SIGNIFICANT PART OF OUR
STATE HERITAGE AND CULTURE.
FROM SAN FRANCISCO'S CHINATOWN
TO CREATE TOWN IN LA AND EVERY
NEIGHBORHOOD IN BETWEEN
INCLUDING MANY IN MY OWN
DISTRICT.
LET US CELEBRATE CALIFORNIA'S
UNIQUE DIVERSITY ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICANS ARE
TREMENDOUS AND RESPECTED PART OF
OUR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LATEST LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS POWER QUE HAN.
MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM
YOUR DESK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
THIS ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LGBT LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
WE ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT AND
SOLIDARITY OF RECOGNIZING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THIS SIMILAR
STRUGGLES THAT THE LGBT
COMMUNITY FACES A SIMILAR TO
THAT OF THE STRUGGLES OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY.
A VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUED SUCCESS OF A P. I. L.
THREE TEAM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND HOPEFULLY IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE IN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
PERHAPS MIGHT SEE THE FIRST.
API LGBT MAYOR OF THAT CITY I
REPRESENTING OUR RESPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES PROBABLY AND WITH
RESPECT TO ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE SEEN NO
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
ON THIS MEASURE.
MR KARA YOU MAY CLOSE ON A C. R.
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'VE BEEN
VERY GRATEFUL TO ALL THOSE THAT
SPOKE IN.
SUPPORT OF A STAR SEVENTY FOUR
REFLECTING THE EXTRAORDINARY
DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE THE API
COMMUNITY ITSELF IS
EXTRAORDINARILY DIVERSE NOTHING
EXEMPLIFIES THAT WE ARE STRONGER
WHEN WE ARE UNITED.
AND WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE BOAT AND ASK THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR COLLECTORS.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA MISTER
KALRA WISHES TO ADD CO AUTHORS
THE FIRST ROLE WILL BE FOR CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE
.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ALL MEMBERS WISHING TO ADD ON AS
CO AUTHORS.
WE CAN CLOSE THE ROLE.
WE HAVE SEVENTY CO AUTHORS THAT
HAVE BEEN ADDED.
THE NEXT VOTE.
IS ON THE BILL WE CAN TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
AYES HAVE IT.
THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED. FOR THE FIFTEENTH
ASSEMBLY OBSERVANCE OF ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH WE WILL RECOGNIZE
A NUMBER OF DISTINGUISHED
HONOREES.
I'M APPOINTING AN ESCORT
COMMITTEE TO BRING OUR SPECIAL
GUESTS ON TO THE FLOOR. FOR A
SPECIAL PRESENTATION.
MEMBERSHIP RETIRE TO THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER.
AS I CALL YOUR NAME ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GLORIA.
TING.
YEP.
MURATSUCHI CHOI.
CHEN.
LOW.
KANSEN CHU SHAO.
FONG.
KALRA.
THIS IS ERIN.
ME.
AND OUR SPECIAL GUEST SENATOR.
DR RICHARD PAN. FOR THE
FIFTEENTH [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY.
EXCUSE ME I ASK ASSEMBLY SPEAKER
ANTHONY RENDON.
ASSEMBLY REPUBLICAN LEADER MARIE
WALDRON.
I CAUCUS CHAIR DAVID CHIU.
AND THE CO CHAIR OF THE JOINT
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN CAUCUS AND SPECIAL
GUEST SENATOR LING LING CHIANG.
TO MOVE TO THE CENTER AISLE TO
RECEIVE OUR HONOREES.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
INTRODUCTIONS OF THE ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER MONTH HONOREES.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ
.
THE HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE IN
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IS JUDY KEY.
SHE'S ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA.
HE AS RETIRED MIDDLE SCHOOL
SCIENCE TEACHER WHO TAUGHT FOR
THREE DECADES OF SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO AND TWO
THOUSAND THREE SHE'S RECOGNIZED
AS A DISTINGUISHED EDUCATOR BY
WHO'S WHO AMONG AMERICA'S
TEACHERS.
SHE WAS ALSO A FORMER
COMMISSIONER ON THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN AFFAIRS.
PLEASE WELCOME THE TWENTY
NINETEEN HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE
IN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT JUDY KEY
.
THE HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE IN
CIVIL RIGHTS QUOTE.
HE'S ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBERS
MURATSUCHI AND TEN STEWART CLOSE
THE FOUNDING PRESIDENT AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE LOS
ANGELES.
QUO IS NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
LEADER AND EXPERT IN RACE
RELATIONS ASIAN AMERICAN STUDIES
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND
PLANTS ARE THESE CIVIL RIGHTS
AND LEGAL SERVICES.
HE WAS NAMED THE MACARTHUR
FOUNDATION FELLOW IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT BECOMING THE FIRST
ASIAN AMERICAN ATTORNEY AND
HUMAN RIGHTS ACTIVIST RECEIVE
THIS HIGHLY PRESTIGIOUS
RECOGNITION.
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS THE GENIUS
GRANT PLEASE WELCOME THE TWENTY
NINETEEN HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE
IN CIVIL RIGHTS DIRECT QUOTE
.
THE HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE IN
THE CULINARY ARTS IS JAMES C.
ABBOUD.
HE IS ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBERS
TING INDEED.
BORN IN THAILAND AND RAISED IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA JAMES IS A
CHEF A PROPRIETOR OF SEVERAL
RESTAURANTS.
CALL ME THE ONLY MISSION STAR
RESTAURANT OPEN SINCE.
TWENTY TEN PARKER FAIR SAN
FRANCISCO SERVING TRADITIONAL
LOTION THAI CUISINE.
IT'S OFF SHE WAS TALKING BIRD IN
OPENS TO MEDICAL AREA AND THE
CASUAL VERY OLD CAN HERE IN WEST
OAKLAND.
NAMED BEST NEW CHEF IN TWENTY
TEN BY FOOD WINE MAGAZINE -- HAS
BEEN RECOGNIZED NOT ONLY FOR A
SKILL AND DEDICATION TO THE
CULINARY ARTS BEFORE REVIVING
THE DINING SCENE IN HIS HOMETOWN
OF OAKLAND.
PLEASE WELCOME THE TWENTY
NINETEEN HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE
IN THE CULINARY ARTS JAMES
SEAFOOD.
THE HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCEIN
ENTERTAINMENT IS THE FILM CRAZY
RICH ASIANS REPRESENTING THE
FILM IS SCREEN WRITER IT'S ELLEN
SHE'S ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBERS
LOW IN KANSEN CHU.
JOHN AND CHIU DIRECTED THE
CONTEMPORARY ROMANTIC COMEDY
CRAZY RICH ASIANS BASED ON THE
CLEAN THE WORLDWIDE BESTSELLER
BY KEVIN FINE.
IT IS THE FIRST FILM BY A MAJOR
HOLLYWOOD STUDIO TO FEATURE A
MAJORITY CAST OF ASIAN DESCENT
IN A MODERN SETTING SINCE THE
JOY LUCK CLUB IN.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE MR TELL
THEM AS A WRITER PRODUCER FOR
FILM AND TELEVISION SHE WROTE
THE SCREENPLAY ADAPTATION OF
CRAZY RICH ASIANS.
PLEASE WELCOME THE TWENTY
NINETEEN HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE
IN ENTERTAINMENT I TELL THEM FOR
THE FILM CRAZY RICH ASIANS
.
THE HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE IN
JOURNALISM IS RICHARD LOUIS.
HE'S ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBERS
CHAO AND FONG.
RICHARD LOUIS IS AN ANCHOR AT
MSNBC AND NBC NEWS HIS CAREER
HAS SPANNED THREE DECADES.
LOUIS BECAME THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN MALE IN AMERICA TO
ANCHOR IT DAILY NATIONAL CABLE
NETWORK NEWS PROGRAM IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN AND RECEIVED
AND HAS RECEIVED VARIOUS AWARDS
FOR HIS REPORTING.
OF CHINESE AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
DESCENT RICHARD IS A FIRST
GENERATION AMERICAN PLEASE
WELCOME THE TWENTY NINETEEN
HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE IN
JOURNALISM RICHARD LOUIS
.
THE HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE IN
PHILANTHROPY IS LOCKED THE CHRIS
NINE SHE'S ESCORTED BY FAMILY
MEMBERS KALRA AN ASSYRIAN.
Là TO CHRIS NINE IS A
TECHNOLOGY ENTREPRENEUR A START
UP INVESTOR AND ENGAGE
PHILANTHROPIST WHO HAS EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE BOTH IN FINANCE AND
BUSINESS MANAGEMENT.
AS WELL AS IN HOPING BOTH YOUNG
COMPANIES AND NONPROFIT SCALE
INNOVATIVE IDEAS TO DELIVER
IMPACT PLEASE WELCOME THE TWENTY
NINETEEN HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE
IN PHILANTHROPY LOTSA CHRISTIAN
ON
THE HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE IN
PUBLIC SERVICE IS MONA PASCAL.
SHE'S ESCORTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA AND SENATOR PAN.
MONA PASCHAL SERVES AS
APPOINTMENT SECRETARY IN THE
OFFICE OF GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
AND IS RESPONSIBLE FOR HELPING
THE GOVERNOR BUILD HIS
ADMINISTRATION BY RECRUITING TOP
CANDIDATES TO SERVE THE STATE.
PRIOR TO HER POSITION PASCHAL
SIR DOES APPOINTMENT SECRETARY
IN THE OFFICE OF GOVERNOR EDMUND
G. BROWN JUNIOR WAS CHIEF OF
STAFF TO CALIFORNIA LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR JOHN GARAMENDI.
AND BECAME ACTING LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR AFTER GARAMENDI WAS
ELECTED TO CONGRESS.
THIS MARKED THE FIRST TIME A
WOMAN ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER OR
FILIPINO AMERICANS SERVED IN
THIS ROLE.
PLEASE WELCOME THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN HONOREE FOR EXCELLENCE
IN PUBLIC SERVICE MONA PASCAL
.
WE ARE HONORED TO HAVE A NUMBER
OF SPECIAL GUESTS PRESENT TODAY.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER OUR
GUESTS FROM THE COMMISSION ON
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN.
AFFAIRS THE COMMISSION IS THE
ONLY ETHNIC STATE COMMISSION IN
CALIFORNIA.
THESE COMMISSIONERS ARE
APPOINTEES OF THE GOVERNOR THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY I WANT
TO WELCOME OUR COMMISSIONERS WHO
ARE WE'RE HERE WITH US TODAY WE
HAVE.
CAR SICK RAMAKRISHNAN
[inaudible]
ALLEN LEAVE.
IS PUT ON BY AN RUSSIAN GIL.
ALL THE LOW.
END SIMON.
PAIN.
THIS GET A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
.
WE ALSO WELCOME ALL OTHER
SPECIAL GUESTS AND FRIENDS WHO
HAVE JOINED US FOR OUR SPECIAL
OBSERVANCE TODAY.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY.
OTHER HONOREES AT TO THE CHAMBER
VIA THE CENTER AISLE LET'S GIVE
THEM ANOTHER ROUND OF APPLAUSE
.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MOVING BACK TO BUSINESS ON THE
FILE.
ASSEMBLY SECOND READING.
CLOCK RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY SEVEN
AND ASSEMBLY DRY RESOLUTION
ELEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
UNANIMOUS CONSENT IS GRANTED FOR
MISTER GALLAGHER.
THIS IS RECONSIDERATION.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS.
CLARK AGREED WITH THE MEN'S.
ASSIGNABLE LEVIN THIRTY EIGHT
WITH THE MEMONS BASED ON THE
NUMBER GALLAGHER.
MISTER GALLAGHER ON THE METHODS.
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
WILL HELP PROTECT MINORS BY
REQUIRING SOCIAL MEDIA PROVIDERS
TO RECEIVE PARENTAL CONSENT.
BEFORE ALLOWING MINORS UNDER THE
AGE OF THIRTEEN TO CREATE SOCIAL
MEDIA ACCOUNTS THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WILL ALLOW COMPANIES
USE ANY F. T. C. APPROVED
VERIFICATION METHOD. TO CERTIFY
PARENTAL CONSENT HI THIS WILL
HELP STANDARDIZE VERIFICATION
METHODS BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND
FEDERAL LAW.
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK -- THE
GENTLEMAN FROM WHERE YOU'RE WHO
HIGHLIGHTED -- THIS ISSUE ON
THURSDAY AND WITH THESE MEMBERS
TAKING A PRIVATE.
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS AND
AMENDMENTS TAKEN A PRIVACY
COMMITTEE THE THE BILL HAS NO
FORMAL OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISS GALLAGHER WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YEAH SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE DOTTED
BILLS OUT TO PRINCETON BACK ON
FILE.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO THE TOP OF
THE THIRD READING FILE FILE
ITEMS FIVE AND SIX PASS AND
RETAIN.
MR MCCARTY IS GOING TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN AB.
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
AND ACTUALLY TO FIREARMS.
MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT THIS MEASURE WHICH
CODIFIES RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
OUR STATE AUDITOR ON FEES.
CHARGED TO THOSE APPLYING FOR A
CALIFORNIA CONCEALED WEAPON
PERMIT A CCW IT'S A NARROW BILL
REALLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT ISSUE
FOCUSING ON FAIRNESS.
I'D LIKE TO START BY SAYING WITH
THE BILL DOESN'TDO IT DOESN'T
CHANGE WHO CAN APPLY FOR IS THE
CW.
DOESN'T CHANGE THE REQUIREMENTS
TO ATTAIN ONE DOESN'T CHANGE WHO
CAN ISSUE A CCW OR ANY OTHER
SUBSTANTIVE LAW IT SIMPLY
REQUIRES IT FEES CHARGED BY CHER
FOR POLICE DEPARTMENT.
COVER THE TRUE COST TO IT ATTAIN
SUCH A PERMIT.
LIKE LOG LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DO
WITH MARRIAGE LICENSES AND
BUILDING PERMITS AND SO FORTH
HERE IN SACRAMENTO OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FACED A DEFICIT OF
NEARLY HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
BECAUSE OF INADEQUATE FEES
CHARGED TO OUR C. C. W.'S.
THESE ARE DOLLARS THAT COULD A
WENT TO MAKING OUR STREETS SAFER
FOCUSING ON YOUTH PROGRAMS AND
SO FORTH IT'S NOT JUST
SACRAMENTO.
OUR STATE AUDITOR AS I MENTIONED
IT OR NOT IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FOCUSING ON THE
COUNTIES OF LA.
SAN DIEGO AND SACRAMENTO SHE
CAME THE CONCLUSION THAT THIS IS
A NEEDED FIX IN OUR STATE LAW.
AND WITH THAT ASK THE RIVAL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROTELLA VOTE.
I TWENTY TWO KNOW.
SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE
TO PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
EIGHT FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
FOR NINETY SIX BY MR LOW THE
CLERK WILL READ.
AT SOME LEVEL FOR NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AND ACTUALLY
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS.
THE SHALLOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FOR NINETY
SIX IS A BUSINESS PROFESSIONS
CLEAN UP CODE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE.
FAMOUS LOW SAYING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS FOR THEIR
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIE THE VOTE I
SEVENTY ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TEN PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN IS AB TWENTY
NINE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK READ WITH
AMENDMENTS.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN.
SURE HOLD ON THE MINUTES I THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER -- AND
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FOUR
MINUTES TODAY.
OF THE BILL REMOVES THE MOST
DISPUTED LAND OF THE S. R. SEVEN
TEN FROM THE FREEWAY AND
EXPRESSWAY CODE.
A LINE IN THE LAW WITH THE
DESIRES OF THE CITIES.
AND THE FINALIZED CALTRANS III
ARE. FOR TOO LONG THE STATE HAS
BEEN TRYING TO DICTATE WHAT THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY CAN DO WITH THIS
AREA.
THESE AMENDMENTS REVERSE THAT
TREND BY REQUIRING CALTRANS AND
LA METRO TO CONSULT WITH THE
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES ON THE
FUTURE PROJECTS.
AND MOVE FORWARD ONLY WITH
PROJECTS THAT ARE AGREED ON IT
ALSO GIVES LOCAL COMMUNITIES THE
FIRST RIGHT OF REFUSAL. TO
UNDEVELOPED LAND TO ENSURE LOCAL
INTERESTS ARE PUT FIRST. FOR
THESE REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN THESE AMENDMENTS.
THEY GIVE US HOLDEN.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE -- SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT.
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL'S
OUTSPRINTED BACK ON FILE.
FILE ITEM TWELVE PASS RETAIN.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN THIS IS
MISTER O'DONNELL [inaudible]
MR O'DONNELL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. THIRTEEN AB
TEN FOURTEEN CORKERY.
AT SOME LEVEL TEN FOURTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO HEALTH
FACILITIES.
MR O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TEN
FOURTEEN WHICH REQUIRES
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH FACILITIES.
TO PROVIDE A ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAY NOTICE TO THE PUBLIC PRIOR
TO DOWNGRADING CHANGING OR
CLOSING THEIR FACILITIES.
A HOSPITAL'S DECISION TO REDUCE
OR ELIMINATE SERVICES CREATE
SERIOUS IS SERIOUS CHALLENGES
FOR A COMMUNITY.
IN MY DISTRICT JUST LAST YEAR
THE COMMUNITY HOSPITAL OF LONG
BEACH CLOSED ITS DOORS.
AFTER ABRUPTLY DIVERTING
EMERGENCY ROOM PATIENTS TO OTHER
HOSPITALS THIS WAS DONE WITH
VERY LITTLE NOTICE TO RESIDENTS
AND THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
AS A RESULT PATIENTS ON MY
COMMUNITY NOW EXPERIENCE LONGER
WAIT TIMES FOR SERVICES LONGER
AMBULANCE TRAVEL TIMES AND
OVERCROWDING AT OTHER HOSPITALS
AND EMERGENCY ROOMS.
THIS EXPERIENCE IS NOT UNIQUE TO
LONG BEACH IS HAPPENED ACROSS
THE STATE.
AB TEN FOURTEEN OVERRIDE
COMMUNITY LEADERS WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FULLY INVESTIGATE
OTHER OPTIONS INCLUDING SECURING
A NEW PROVIDER. TO PREVENT THE
CLOSURE OF A CRITICAL HOSPITAL
THAT WAS THE PROBLEM LONG BEACH
HAD WE HAD MORE TIME WE'VE COULD
POTENTIALLY GOT ANOTHER OPERATOR
TO COME IN AND OPERATE.
THE HOSPITAL.
LEAST THIS BILL ALLOWS PATIENTS
AND RESIDENTS TO BETTER PREPARE
FOR THEIR NEXT EMERGENCY WHEN
THEIR LOCAL HOSPITAL IS GONE.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE AT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
TYLER AYE AYES FORTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS FOURTEEN THROUGH
SIXTEEN PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN IS AB.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN CORPORATE.
AS SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN OH SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
THIS WITH YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN
CONTINUES THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S WORK IN INCREASING
CHARTER SCHOOL TRANSPARENCY.
THIS BILL INCREASES LOCAL
CONTROL BY ELIMINATING LOOPHOLES
IN THE CURRENT LAW WHICH ALLOW
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO OPERATE
OUTSIDE OF THEIR AUTHORIZING
DISTRICT.
THIS BILL RESTORES THE RIGHT OF
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS TO HAVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE SCHOOLS
LOCATED WITHIN THEIR GEOGRAPHIC
BOUNDARIES AND CLARIFIES THE
JURISDICTIONAL SOVEREIGNTY OF
DULY ELECTED SCHOOL BOARDS AND
THEIR ROLE IN PUBLIC OVERSIGHT.
AB FIFTY NO SEVEN SIX TO ADDRESS
CONSISTENT AN ONGOING CHALLENGES
THAT LEAVE IMPACTED DISTRICTS
WITH NO RECOURSE OTHER THAN
COSTLY LITIGATION.
ELEAZAR TASKED WITH ENSURING
STUDENT SUCCESS WITHOUT SUCCESS
IS BUILT OFF TRUST FROM THE
COMMUNITY WITHIN THE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY AND THE
COMMUNITY THAT IS IMPACTED BY IT.
THIS WAS THE CASE IN MY TENURE
ON THE NEW HALL SCHOOL BOARD WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE TOOLS NORTH
ALREADY TO EXERCISE OVERSIGHT ON
A SCHOOL THAT WAS AUTHORIZED BY
ANOTHER SCHOOL DISTRICT BUT WAS
PHYSICALLY LOCATED IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
WE COULD NOT DO ARE DULY ELECTED
JOB TO LOOK OUT FOR AN ADVOCATE
ON BEHALF OF STUDENTS WERE THE
FAMILIES IN THE SCHOOL NOR COULD
WE ADVOCATE FOR ANY MITIGATING
FACTORS TO DECREASE THE IMPACT
ON THAT SCHOOLS NEIGHBORS.
AS A RECENT CAL MATTERS ARTICLE
INDICATES THE CHARTER IN MY
DISTRICTS CASE CLOSED IF YOU IN
A FEW SHORT YEARS DUE TO
WOEFULLY MISMANAGED FINANCES
THROUGH THEIR CMO.
AS HAD BEEN PREDICTED BY THE
MULTIPLE ELLIE ETS WHO WOULD
CAREFULLY VETTED AND DENIED
THEIR ORIGINAL PETITION.
THE AUTHORIZED OR IN THIS CASE
WAS A SMALL RURAL RURAL DISTRICT
IN FINANCIAL DISTRESS DUE TO
DECLINING ENROLLMENT.
THIS IS OCCURRING IN DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THE LOOPHOLE IN THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ACCESSIBLE RIVERSIDE OF
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES FOR
STRUGGLING ELEAZAR IN A MANNER
INCONSISTENT NOT ONLY WITH THE
INTENT OF THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
ACT.
BUT WITH OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
ADEQUATELY FUND ALL DISTRICTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN DECLINING
ENROLLMENT.
THE COST OF OPERATION DON'T
DIMINISH IN DIRECT PROPORTION TO
EIGHTY A ALLOCATION.
AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN ULTIMATELY
IS ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL AND
MAKING SURE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE TOOLS AND THE POWER TO BEST
UTILIZE TAXPAYER DOLLARS FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CHILDREN.
AND FOR THOSE LOCAL ENTITIES TO
DO WHAT THEY WERE ELECTED TO DO.
AMOS WITH.
MISTER MURATSUCHI YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I RISE.
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN I BELIEVE THAT
THAT WE SHOULD SUPPORT GOOD
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
BUT WE SHOULD CRACKDOWN ON BAD
I HAVE.
A GROUP OF CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT
SERVE KIDS IN MY DISTRICT AS
WELL SINCE ROUNDING
NEIGHBORHOODS.
ENVIRONMENTAL CHARTER SCHOOLS
[inaudible]
THEY EDUCATE.
OVER ALMOST 90% OF THE STUDENTS
ARE LATINO AND AFRICAN AMERICAN.
AND ABOUT 96% OF THE GRADUATING
SENIORS WERE ACCEPTED BY A FOUR
YEAR COLLEGE.
HOWEVER THEY ARE FACING GO A ONE
ISSUE WHERE THEY WERE CHARTERED.
AND AND AUTHORIZED IN INGLEWOOD
BUT THEY HAD TO MOVE THEIR
SCHOOL BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
FACILITIES. TO LESS WITHIN A
MILE. TO THE CITY OF GARDENA --
I IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE AUTHOR.
HAS TAKEN AMENDMENTS AND IS
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE EXECUTE THE INTENT.
OF PROPER OVERSIGHT AND CRACKING
DOWN ON BAD CHARTER SCHOOLS BUT
MAKING SURE.
THAT WE ARE MAKING COMMONSENSE
AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO GOOD CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE.
I ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
MISS SMITH YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SOUTH BAY
MAKES EXCELLENT POINTS MEMBERS I
DARE SAY THAT ALL OF US HAVE
PROBABLY HAD A GREAT EXPERIENCE
WITH A CHARTER SCHOOL.
SOME OF THEM ARE OUT THERE DOING
REALLY WONDERFUL AND MIRACULOUS
THINGS.
BUT WHAT WE NEED TO REMEMBER IS
THAT THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOL ACT WAS FOR
CHARTERS TO BE EXACTLY THAT.
LABORATORIES OF LEARNING THAT
WOULD THEN CREATE A FEEDBACK
LOOP SYSTEMIC TO OUR GREATER
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM TO ENHANCE
THE LEARNING IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF EVERY STUDENT.
THE MEASURES MY COLLEAGUES AND I
ON THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE ARE
UNDERTAKING IS TO RESTORE US TO
THAT ORIGINAL INTENT AB FIFTEEN
OH SEVEN IS A FIRST STEP ON THAT
JOURNEY I APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE AYES FIFTY TWO KNOWS.
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
EVERYWHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB THREE OH NINE
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE OH NINE BY
SIMPLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
ACTUALLY THE VEHICLES
[inaudible]
MR MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
EMAIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS POLICE CARS
ARE IMPORTANT ARTIFACTS AT THAT
POLICE HISTORICAL SOCIETY'S DUE
TO THEIR HISTORICAL AND
COMMUNITY SIGNIFICANCE AB THREE
OH NINE WILL GIVE FEDERAL STATE
OR LOCAL POLICE MUSEUMS AND
OTHER.
HISTORICAL SOCIETIES THE ABILITY
TO DISPLAY AT MUSEUMS AND
ADVANCE RETIRED POLICE VEHICLES
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN IBM.
VIGOROUS MAIENSCHEIN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRED VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF THE
START OF A ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SEVENTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FOLLOW
NINETEEN AB SIX SIX FOR
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER AND
ACTUALLY THE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT.
SURE COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
CURRENTLY THE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT LAW NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN ACT ALLOWS FOR PERMANENT A
CAPACITY STATUS FOR ITS MEMBERS.
THIS STATUS INTERPRETED
DIFFERENTLY AMONG THE TWENTY
THREE SEVEN THAT RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS FOR SOME OF THE SAFETY
MEMBERS.
SB SIX SIX FOUR ADDRESSES THIS
INCONSISTENCY FOR ONE OF THE
SYSTEMS THE SECOND OF COUNTY
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
SB SIX SIX FOUR WILL CREATE A
FIVE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM THE BILL
PERSPECTIVE REMAIN SAID IT TOO
ALL SCORERS PROCESSES AND
MEDICAL.
EXAMINATIONS SB SIX SIX FOUR
PROVIDES TIME TO STUDY THE
BALANCE BETWEEN RETIREMENT
SYSTEM IN THE FAIRNESS
PROTECTING EMPLOYEES OF THE
PUBLIC A PATH STATED.
IN THE LINE OF DUTY OUR SPECS WE
ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THING WAS COOPER SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLUB THE ROLE.
MEMBERS FUNDS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
BUT I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE PASS RETAIN FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO AB FIVE OH SIX
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE OH
SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER KALRA AND
ACTUALLY TO HEALTH FACILITIES.
WHICH KALRA EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE OH SIX
REPLACE AN OUTDATED AND
INCONSISTENT CAUSATION TEST.
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REJECTED
WITH THE STANDARD USED TO DATE
AND DETERMINE NEGLIGENCE
SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR FOR THE
HIGHEST LEVEL CITATION OF LONG
TERM CARE FACILITY.
CAN BE ISSUED A CLASS DOUBLE A A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE THE CLASS A.
A. AFTER UNDERGOING A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION OF SUSPICIOUS
DEATHS.
AND DETERMINES A REGULATION
DESIGNED TO KEEP THE RESIDENT
ALIVE AND SAFE WAS NOT FOLLOW
DUE TO FACILITY NEGLIGENCE AND
THE NEGLIGENCE WAS THE LEADING
CAUSE THE RESULT IN THE DEATH OF
THAT RESIDENTS.
CURRENTLY THE LAW SAYS IT MUST
BE A DIRECT PROXIMATE CAUSE THE
DEATH WHICH IS A STANDARD THAT
HAS BEEN REJECTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
BECAUSE IT IS A CONFUSING
STANDARD.
SUBSTANTIAL DOCTOR IS NOT A
LOWER STANDARD FOR CAUSATION AND
THE BURDEN OF PROOF IS STILL ON
THE DEPARTMENT. TO SUBSTANTIATE
THE CITATION.
FACILITIES HAVE THE ABILITY TO
APPEAL THIS A CITATION THE
SUPERIOR COURT.
THE COURT IS MUCH BETTER SUITED
TO APPLY THE CURRENT NEGLIGENCE
STANDARD RATHER THAN USING AN
OUTDATED INCONSISTENT STANDARD.
OF THAT CAUSES CONFUSION.
DIRECT PRODUCT DIRECT PROBABLY
CAUSES NOT HAD THE
CONTEMPORANEOUSLY HISTORY OF
LEGAL PRECEDENT.
SO JUDGES DON'T HAVE AS MUCH
GUIDANCE AND APPLYING THE
OUTDATED STANDARD.
ALSO AB FIVE OH SIX A DOT STATE
AUDITOR RECOMMENDATIONS TO
INCREASE LONG TERM CARE FACILITY
CITATION AMOUNTS.
WHICH HAVE NOT CHANGED IN EIGHT
YEARS FOR CLASS BE CITATIONS AND
NINETEEN YEARS FOR CLASS A. AND
DOUBLE A. CITATIONS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN AND HEALTH
COMMITTEE REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
INCREASE TO MORE CLOSELY REFLECT
THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX AS
REQUESTED BY THE OPPOSITION WE
HAVE ALSO TAKEN A NUMBER OF
OTHER SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED.
BY OPPOSITION IN COMMITTEE.
IT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE BAD PERFORMING SCHOOL
NURSING FACILITIES AND OTHER
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTION.
ESPECIALLY WERE TALKING WITH
FACILITIES NEGLIGENCE WAS BUT
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR RESIDENTS
DEATH THE DEPARTMENT TAKES
EXTREME CARE IN APPLYING THE
CITATIONS IN THE PRIMARY USE.
IS A PLACE OF BAD.
PERFORMING FACILITY ON WATCH SO
THE QUALITY OF CARE CAN BE
IMPROVED FOR FUTURE RESIDENTS
WHEN ISSUING CITATIONS
DEPARTMENT IS NOT LOOKING TO
BECAUSE AND I NEED A FACILITY
CLOSURE.
EVEN THOUGH THE LAW ALLOWS FOR
ALLOWS IT FOR REPEATED CLASS
DOUBLY VIOLATIONS.
AND IS ONLY DONE SO TWICE IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS.
I DON'T AFTER ALL OTHER REMEDIES
WERE EXHAUSTED.
RATHER THE DEPARTMENT TAKES
MEASURES TO TRY AND RAISE THE
QUALITY OF CARE TO PREVENT
FUTURE VIOLATIONS.
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD IN THE
SENATE HOPEFULLY I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION AND PLAN
ON TAKING AN AMENDMENT TO DELETE
THE ABILITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OR REYES COUNTY AMOUNTS BASED
UPON.
COMPLETION.
AB FIVE OR SIX IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO PROTECTING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
THOUSANDS OF AGE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED OTHER MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS BY HOLDING
ACCOUNTABLE THOSE FEW BAD ACTORS
FOUND TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
RESIDENTS HARM.
OR DEATH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THINGS KALRA DOCTOR WOULD
CORRECTNESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE OH SIX THE
BILL WAS HEARD AND HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND WHERE THE AUTHOR
TOOK SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES.
AND CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE AUTHOR
CONTINUES TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS -- TO FINE TUNE THE
BILL IT'S VERY IMPORTANT HOWEVER
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HOLD NURSING
HOMES ACCOUNTABLE TO PROVIDE THE
BEST CARE TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS.
CITATIONS THAT THE OPPOSITION IS
CONCERNED WITH OUR SOCI WITH THE
DEATH OF A PATIENT.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH TWO HUNDRED NINETY
SIX DOUBLE A. CITATIONS WERE
ISSUED OR AND CLOSE FROM JANUARY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TO JANUARY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND AND 1874%
HAVE BEEN APPEALED.
OF THOSE ONLY 17% WERE UPHELD
77% REDUCE AND 1% WERE DISMISSED
ALL TOGETHER.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND ALLOW THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH FACILITIES
AND THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THAT
WHEN A VULNERABLE PATIENT DIES.
THE PENALTIES ARE APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOOD MISTER
VOEPEL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I ALSO RISE TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE OH SIX I BELIEVE THIS
IS A BIPARTISAN BILL.
AND I POINT OUT TO ALL MY
COLLEAGUES THAT.
WE HAVE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IN VARIOUS TYPES OF NURSING
HOMES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
OUT OF FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND WE
AVERAGE NINETEEN DOUBLE A
ATTACKS.
THAT'S WHAT I CONSIDER HIM A TAX.
ON SENIOR CITIZENS -- THESE
PEOPLE DIED.
AND MANY TIMES THEY GET LOWERED
TO SINGLE A SIMPLY BECAUSE OF
EXHAUSTION.
BY ARE OVERWORKED SYSTEM.
SO I STRONGLY STRONGLY URGE ALL
MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL IT'S A GOOD [inaudible]
ONE AND IT IS AN AREA THAT'S
NEGLECTED AND I REMIND EVERYONE
IN THIS ROOM.
THAT ROUGHLY 18220% OF YOU WILL
END UP IN A FACILITY.
WHEN YOU'RE MY AGE OR OLDER?
SO YOU'RE TAKING CARE OF AND
HAVE HOLDING FOR YOURSELF IN A
WAY HERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS VOEPEL.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
ON THE ITEM MISTER CALL OR YOU
MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH.
THE LAST ONE I BOUGHT THANK
MISTER.
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF USER TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MY RESERVES ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIE THAT ICE FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THREE IS AB EIGHT EIGHT
ONE BY MR BLOOM CORP OR RE
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY ONE BY
SOMETHING NUMBER BLOOM AND
ACTUALLY THE HOUSING.
MR BLOOM YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS ARE AS
YOU KNOW AND IT INNOVATIVE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTION FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE PURSUANT.
TO OUT REFORM LAWS THAT WE
PASSED A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
THOUSANDS OF BEEN BUILT OR
PERMITTED ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT BARRIERS TO EIGHTY YOU
CONSTRUCTION REMAIN IN AB EIGHT
EIGHT ONE SEEKS TO REDUCE SOME
OF THESE BARRIERS BY UPDATING
AND CLARIFYING PROVISIONS OF THE
EIGHTY YEAR STATUTE.
SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF
DEFINITIONAL Là A REQUIREMENTS --
AT THAT ARE CHANGED IN THIS BILL.
AND AS YOU KNOW EIGHTY USER COST
EFFECTIVE. TO BUILD IT AND THEY
HELP INCREASE OUR FOUR WHEEL
HOUSING OPTIONS WITHOUT
DEPLETING LIMITED STATE FUNDS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I THINK IT WAS BLOOM.
SAY NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CARPOOL OVER THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRED OF THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE SIXTY THREE KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS TWENTY FOUR THROUGH
FORTY THREE PASS AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY FOUR AB TWELVE
SIXTY FOUR FOR COREY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SIXTY FOUR
BY FAMILY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
HEALING ARTS DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
THIS PETRIE-NORRIS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR AB.
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR THIS BILL
EXPANDS ACCESS TO BIRTH CONTROL
FOR CALIFORNIA WOMEN BY.
CORRECTING AND CLARIFYING SOME
BIG TELEHEALTH LIES AND REMOVING
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY OBSTACLES
WOMEN WHO WISH TO ORDER BIRTH
CONTROL USING A SMARTPHONE APP.
AS WE ALL KNOW WHAT BIRTH
CONTROL AND THE ADVENT OF SMART
AND EFFECTIVE FAMILY PLANNING
HAS HAD A PROFOUND AND POSITIVE
IMPACT ON WOMEN'S LIVES AND AND
ENABLING US TO CONTROL.
OUR DESTINIES IN OUR PERSONAL
LIVES IN OUR FAMILY LIVES AND IN
OUR PROFESSIONAL LIVES.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD IS SPONSORING
THIS SPELL VERY PROUD TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THEM TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO BIRTH CONTROL FOR
CALIFORNIA WOMEN.
THIS BILL IS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE THAT.
THANK YOU MISS PETRIE-NORRIS.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES [inaudible]
FIFTY FOUR CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE THAT BILL.
PASSES.
FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE PASS AND
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY SIX IS AB.
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND ACTUALLY THE DRIVING
PRIVILEGES.
MISTER JONES SAWYER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN A
BILL THAT REPEALED LOOK OUR
COURTS OF TOWARD THE TO SUSPEND
DRIVING PRIVILEGES FOR VANDALISM.
IN RECENT YEARS CALIFORNIA'S
REMOVING TOWARDS ENDING THE
PRACTICE OF SUSPENDING DRIVING
PRIVILEGES FOR INFRACTIONS
UNRELATED TO DRIVING SUCH AS
UNPAID FINES AND TRUANCY.
CURRENTLY A COURT IS REQUIRED TO
SUSPEND OR DELAYED DRIVING PEARL
PRIVILEGES FOR ONE TO THREE
YEARS WHEN A PERSON IS CONVICTED
OF VANDALISM.
THE SUSPENSION OF DRIVING
PRIVILEGES DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR WHICH LIMITS
OPTIONS TO GET TO WORK SCHOOL OR
MEDICAL VISITS IN ADDITION
REPEALING HIS AUTHORIZATION CAN
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS
TO THE STATE'S.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS JONES SAWYER SAYING
NO YES THIS MELENDEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER -- SO
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS BILL
ALSO DOES SOMETHING ELSE WHICH
IS -- ELIMINATES A SUSPENSION OF
DRIVER'S LICENSES FOR THESE
THREE TYPES OF VANDALISM --
VANDALIZING WITH THE CAUSTIC
CHEMICAL GENERIC VANDALISM AND
FELONY HATE CRIME VANDALISM OF A
CHURCH SYNAGOGUE MOSQUE TEMPLE
RELIGIOUS SCHOOL OR CEREMONY.
IS THAT WHAT WE WANT TO DO.
WHEN THEY DO SO REDUCE THE CRIME
[inaudible] FOR DEFACING.
A JEWISH CEMETERY.
A SYNAGOGUE A MOSQUE THE TEMPLE
IS THAT THE MESSAGE WE WANT TO
SEND.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE BILL
DOES IF YOU READ IT.
I WOULD URGE IN ABOUT.
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER JONES SAWYER
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND LET ME CLARIFY.
AS THE AUTHOR OF AB SEVEN EIGHT
FIVE AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT
PREVENTS INDIVIDUALS CONVICTED
OF HATE CRIMES.
FROM OBTAINING A FARM WITHIN TEN
YEARS OF THAT CONVICTION.
I DO NOT WANT TO REDUCE
PENALTIES FOR HATE CRIMES.
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN WILL NOT
AFFECT ANY OTHER CURRENT
PENALTIES.
OR CODE SECTIONS THAT ADDRESS
HATE CRIMES.
OR VANDALIZING RELIGIOUS
FACILITIES.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS FOR THE
PROSECUTION OF SOMEONE WHO IS
BELIEVED TO HAVE COMMITTED AN
ACT OF VANDALISM.
AS A HATE CRIME OR AN ACTOR BY
BIAS IF THAT PERSON IS CONVICTED.
THEY WILL BE SENTENCED TO A YEAR
IN COUNTY JAIL.
OR MORE IMPORTANT STATE PRISON.
IN ADDITION A SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT.
OF ONE TO FOUR YEARS CAN BE
APPLIED TO THEIR SENTENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TELL YOU THAT I
AS FIFTY ONE KNOWS.
NINETEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN A. B. SIXTEEN TWENTY
TWO FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS.
CLARK AGREED WITH THE MEN.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO
WITH THE MEMONS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO.
MS CARILLO YOU MAY OPEN ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I THESE ARE AMENDMENTS
TO SIXTEEN TWENTY TWO WHICH WILL
CLARIFY THAT INCLUDING A FAMILY
PHYSICIAN ON THE NURSE MIDWIFERY
ADVISORY.
COMMITTEE UNDER THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING IS OPTIONAL I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THEY GIVE US CREEL WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
DOCTOR THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT A.
B. [inaudible]
FOURTEEN HUNDRED CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN HUNDRED
BY FAMILY MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE
ACTUALLY TO WORKERS COMPENSATION.
WAS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
HUNDRED AND SURE CIVILIAN
EMPLOYEES OF A CITY COUNTY OR
SPECIAL DISTRICT WHO ARE EXPOSED
IN THE LINE OF DUTY TO ACTIVE
FIRES.
WERE CARCINOGENIC MATERIALS
CARCINOGENIC MATERIALS FROM
FIREFIGHTING OPERATIONS RECEIVE
FULL MEDIA AND DISABILITY
COVERAGE IF THEY DEVELOP CANCER
THAT HAS BEEN LINKED TO EXPOSURE
TO FIRES BASED ON THE CRITERIA.
ESTABLISHED TO DETERMINE
FIREFIGHTERS ELIGIBILITY FOR
PRESUMPTIVE COVERAGE IN THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR CODE.
THESE CIVILIAN EMPLOYEES SERVING
COUNTY FIRE SERVICE OUTFITS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
THEIR FIRE MECHANICS FIRE
EQUIPMENT MECHANICS AND OTHER
MECHANIC WORKERS.
THEY REPAIR AND MAINTAIN FIRE
SERVICE VEHICLES SUCH AS FIRE
TRUCKS ARE HELICOPTERS AND THE
EQUIPMENT USED BY FIRE FIGHTERS
TO BATTLE ACTIVE BLAZE.
THE RIGORS OF THESE WORKERS
DAILY WORK INCREASES THEIR
LIKELIHOOD OF EXPOSURE. TO SUCH
CARCINOGENS SUCH AS BENZENE
CHLOROFORM SUIT STYRENE AND
FORMALDEHYDE AMONG OTHER
CONTAMINANTS.
THESE EMPLOYEES ARE INHERENTLY
IN HEALTH IN DANGER MEANT THEY
FACE RISKS THAT ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY EVEN HIGHER FOR
SOME SPECIFIC TYPES OF CANCERS.
THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY INSURE
THAT THE REBUTTAL REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION REGARDING ON DUTY
CANCER DIAGNOSES AVAILABLE TO
FIREFIGHTERS EXTENDS TO THE
CIVILIAN SUPPORT PERSONNEL AND
MECHANIC CLASSIFICATIONS WITH
LEGITIMATE EXPOSURE. TO ACTIVE
FIRES OR THE HAZARDS RESULTING
FROM THEM DUE TO THEIR WORK
DUTIES.
I JUST WANT TO ALSO ADD THAT ON
MY TOUR OF ONE OF THE YARDS.
I WAS TOLD ABOUT RAY OR TEASE.
WHO HAD WORKED FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AS A FIRE MECHANIC?
AND HAD EVENTUALLY DECIDED THAT
HE WANTED TO BECOME A
FIREFIGHTER AND IT WAS THEN WHEN
HE WENT FOR HIS EXAM.
THAT IT WAS DETERMINED THAT HE
HAD STAGE FOUR CANCER AND HE
DIED JUST MONTHS LATER.
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED.
WITH A BILL LIKE AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
MR GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE AS WELL TO
SUPPORT A. B..
FOURTEEN HUNDRED AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED GRANT CIVILIAN EMPLOYEES
OF A FIRE DEPARTMENT THE SAME
WORKERS COMP RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS AS FIREFIGHTERS IF
THE CIVILIAN EMPLOYEES
EXPERIENCE CANCER.
THE CIVILIAN EMPLOYEES SERVE AND
COUNTY FIRE SERVICE OUTFITS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
THEY ARE FIRE MECHANICS FIRE
EQUIPMENT MECHANICS AND OTHER
MECHANIC WORKERS.
THE FIRE -- MECHANICS DO THEIR
JOBS WITH LIMITED STANDARD ISSUE
PHYSICAL PROTECTIVE GEAR
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE VIRTUALLY
NO PROTOCOLS TO ENSURE THE
MECHANICS WILL BE WORKING ON
VEHICLES OR EQUIPMENT.
THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH A DIG
DECONTAMINATION PROCESS PRIOR TO
THE START OF THEIR WORK.
AS A MATTER OF FACT WHEN
FIREFIGHTERS RETURN FROM
FIGHTING A FIRE.
THEIR TURNOUTS GO THROUGH OR
SUPPOSED TO GO THROUGH WITH THE
CAT A DEED -- TO DECONTAMINATION
PROCESS BUT THESE MECHANICS ARE
EXPOSED TO THE SAME CANCER
CAUSING CONTAMINANTS.
AND THEIR CLOTHES THEY GET TAKEN
HOME AND WASHED IN THE SAME
ENVIRONMENT AS THEIR CHILDREN'S
CLOTHES.
SO I VOTED FOR THIS BILL IN
ASSEMBLY INSURANCE COMMITTEE IN
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ALL EMPLOYEES TO
HAVE THE SAME RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS WHEN IT COMES TO A
PERSON'S HEALTH.
I ENCOURAGE ALLOF MY COLLEAGUES
TO RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS ISSUE AND TO SUPPORT A
SPORT WITH YOUR VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU. TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL.
THEY WAS CHRISTMAS FLORA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE THE CIVILIAN FIRE
PERSONNEL THAT ARE CALLED TO THE
FRONT LINES REVISED MECHANICAL.
INTO WORK ON A QUICK RETURNING
FROM A FIRE ARE PROVIDE THE SAME
LEVEL CANCER PRESUMPTIONS
PROVIDED TO FIREFIGHTERS AND
JUST LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE BILLS
IT WAS STATED WITH THESE MEN AND
WOMEN THAT WORK ON OUR EQUIPMENT
WHEN WE COME BACK FROM A FIRE.
OR A REPORTED AN IMPORTANT PART
OF OUR DAILY JOBS WE NEED THEM
TO BE HAVE THE SAME PROTECTIONS
FIREFIGHTERS A MEMBER FOR THOSE
REASONS I ASKED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
ON THIS ITEM IS KAMLAGER-DOVE
YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH THANK YOU
I JUST WANT TO THANK MY
GENTLEMAN COLLEAGUES FOR OTHER
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK LOCAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE.
TYLER I SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS FORTY NINE AND FIFTY
PASS AND RETAIN WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTY ONE AB TEN FIFTY THREE BY
MISTER DALLI CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALLY AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES DISTRICTS.
RICHARD LA THEY MISTER SPEAKER
TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB TEN
FIFTY THREE WHICH RELATES TO THE
FALLEN LEAF LAKE IN LAKE TAHOE
AREA.
THIS BILL EXPRESSED THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S AUDIT.
OF THE FALL LEAF LAKE COMMUNITY
SERVICE DISTRICT AS REQUESTED BY
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE SERVICES --
AUDIT COMMITTEE J. LACK IN
AUGUST TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THOUGHT IS EXPECTED EARLY THIS
SUMMER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AT
WHICH TIME WE WILL AMEND THIS
BILL REFLECT.
THE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS
THIS BILL IS A JOY TO DENNIS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ENGLISH DAILY SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TELL YOU ABOUT AYE.
SIXTY NINE OH ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO AND
FIFTY THREE PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR AB NINE
FORTY THREE CORKERY.
A SOME PEOPLE NINE FORTY THREE
BY SOME MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
MR CHILL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL WOULD
ADDRESS AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AS
IT IMPACTS OUR CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE STUDENTS WE ALL KNOW
MANY STUDENTS WHO ARE ONE
FINANCIAL EMERGENCY AWAY FROM
BEING FORCED TO DROP OUT.
DUE TO AN EVICTION A MEDICAL
INCIDENT OR CAR ACCIDENT ONE IN
FIVE OF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS CAN'T AFFORD ONE MORE
DOLLARS IN UNEXPECTED COSTS.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO ESTABLISH EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID GRANTS IN
COMPARISON TO TRADITIONAL
FINANCIAL AID AWARDED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
EMERGENCY FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS
AND OTHER STATES PROVIDE SMALL
GRANTS FOR STUDENTS WITH
EMERGENCIES AT RISK OF DROPPING
OUT MID TERM THEY'VE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL ASSISTING 90% OF ALL
STUDENTS. TO FINISH THEIR TERMS
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO USE
STUDENT EQUITY AND ACHIEVEMENT
DOLLARS TO FUND SMALL GRANTS TO
STUDENTS I APPRECIATE THE
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN VOTE
THROUGH VARIOUS COMMITTEES.
AND ASK FOR A VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER Q. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
QUIRK LOCAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WE'VE ALREADY DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE THAT BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM.
FIFTY SIX AC ARE SEVENTY FIVE
OOKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
OBERNOLTE AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
LYME DISEASE AWARENESS MONTH.
MR OBERNOLTE ON THE RESOLUTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
LYME DISEASE IS A DEBILITATING
BACTERIAL INFECTION SPREAD BY
THE BITE OF AN INFECTED TECH.
IT IS NOTORIOUSLY DIFFICULT. TO
DIAGNOSE AND TO TREAT.
AND THAT IS WHY ALTHOUGH THERE
ARE THIRTY THOUSAND CASES
REPORTED IN THE UNITED STATES
EVERY YEAR.
UP 290% OF CASES GO UNREPORTED
FOR SEVERAL YEARS WHICH MAKES
THE TRUE NUMBER OF CASES IN THE
UNITED STATES OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND EVERY YEAR. TO GIVE YOU
AN IDEA OF HOW FAST THAT IS THAT
IS SUBSTANTIALLY MORE THAN THE
NUMBER OF WOMEN.
DIAGNOSED WITH BREAST CANCER
EVERY YEAR AND IT'S OVER SIX
TIMES MORE THAN THE NUMBER OF
NEW HIV AND AIDS INFECTIONS
REPORTED EVERY YEAR SO THIS IS
NOTHING SHORT.
OF AN EPIDEMIC. ONE OF THIS MY
STAFF MEMBERS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL SUFFERS FROM THIS
DISEASE AND I CAN TELL YOU FROM
FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE JUST HOW
INCREDIBLY DEBILITATING AND
DIFFICULT TO LIVE WITH.
IT IS THIS RESOLUTION ACR
SEVENTY FIVE DECLARES THE MONTH
OF MAY AS LYME DISEASE AWARENESS
MONTH TO BRING AWARENESS TO THIS
DISEASE THE PREVENTION OF THE
DISEASE AND HOPEFULLY RESEARCH
TOWARDS A CURE FOR THAT DISEASE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MISTER PATTERSON HERE RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU.
SPEAKER A MEMBERS UP.
AS A MISTER GROW OBERNOLTE OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BIG BEAR.
THIS IS AN EPIDEMIC BUT I WANT
TO FOCUS ON AN INDIVIDUAL.
A WONDERFUL PERSON AND A FAMILY
FRIEND. ONE OF THESE RECENT
DEATHS WAS IN FRESNO ALEX HUDSON.
DIED DUE TO COMPLICATIONS FROM
LYME DISEASE AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY TWO IN MARCH OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALEX HAD LIVED WITH THE
DISEASE FOR OVER TEN YEARS.
SUFFERING FROM CHRONIC JOINT
PAIN AND FATIGUE BEFORE DOCTORS
CORRECTLY IDENTIFIED HER
SYMPTOMS FOR WHAT THEY WERE.
LYME DISEASE.
THE DISEASE HAD ADVANCED SO MUCH
SHE ALSO CONTRACTED MAST CELL
ACTIVATION WHICH GAVE HER AN
ALLERGIC REACTION TO ALMOST
EVERYTHING SHE ATE OR DRANK.
BUT DESPITE HER PAIN.
ALEX SOUGHT TO SPREAD AWARENESS
OF LYME DISEASE AN IMPROVING
TESTING AND DIAGNOSIS SHE
ADVOCATED FOR OTHERS.
UNTIL SHE WAS TAKEN.
BY THIS DISEASE.
AND SO IN HONOR OF ALEX AND ALL
OF THE OTHERS FACING THIS
TERRIBLE AILMENT -- THEY SUFFER
OFTENTIMES IN CONFUSION AND
SILENCE.
SO I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF A
C. R. SEVENTY FIVE IN THE CLERK
MAY.
TWENTY NINETEEN AS LYME DISEASE
AWARENESS MONTH ON BEHALF OF
ALEX AND ALL THE OTHERS.
THANK YOU.
DAVIS PATTERSON SCENE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OF THE
RESOLUTION.
MR OBERNOLTE YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES LYME DISEASE
IS TREATABLE BUT ONLY IF IT IS
RECOGNIZED AND TREATED EARLY
OTHERWISE THERE IS NO CURE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
VOTED ACR SEVENTY FIVE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CALL AUTHORS
MISTER SPEAKER.
AVERAGE THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK LOCAL.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS CO
AUTHORS.
ON A C. R..
SEVENTY FIVE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
THERE ARE.
LOCAL CLOSER ROLE SIXTY NINE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE AT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED AND MR OBERNOLTE BACK TO
YOU FOR YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE MEMBERS OF
THE SACRAMENTO LIME SUPPORT
GROUP AND NORA THOMAS OF THE
LIMELIGHT FOUNDATION THEY'VE
COME TO CAPITOL DAY TO HELP
RAISE AWARENESS OF LYME DISEASE.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT THEY
PROVIDE VITAL SUPPORT SERVICES
FOR THOSE THAT SUFFER FOR THEM
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM
TO SACRAMENTO.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM FIFTY
SEVEN A. B. TWELVE AWAIT BY MR
TING CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE AWAIT MY
FAMILY MEMBER TING ANOTHER IS
UNLIKELY TO TAXATION.
MR TANK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUR BODY PASSED
SB ONE HUNDRED WHICH SET THE
GOAL OF HAVING. 1100% RENEWABLE
ENERGY BY. TWENTY FORTY FIVE ONE
OF THOSE TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL
IS GETTING READY TO SUNSET WHICH
IS THE PROHIBITION ON THE
UTILITY USERS TAX.
THIS BILL SIMPLY EXTENDS THE
SUNSET DATE ON THE PROHIBITION
ON LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IMPOSING.
A UTILITY USER TAX ON CLEAN
ENERGY.
WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR US FOR AYE
VOTE FOR A. B. TWELVE AWAY.
THANK YOU LISTINGS SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE
VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WHERE TO PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
FIFTY EIGHT WE'RE FILE ITEM?
FIFTY NINE AB TEN SIXTY TWO
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMON AND
ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION.
THE MODEL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TEN
SIXTY TWO WILL PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION CREDITS
AND PARTICIPATE IN EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND BASIC RESPONSE
TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
SKILLS NEEDED TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
AND ASSIST OTHERS IN THE EVENT
OF AN EMERGENCY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MOM.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK LOCAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM SIXTY AND SIXTY ONEPASS
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
SIXTY TWO AB SIX TEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE AND I
PLAN TO ELECTIONS THE SURE OF
ADULTERY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS CURRENT STATE
LAW REQUIRES THAT WHEN THE BOND
IS PLACED ON THE BALLOT FOR
VOTER APPROVAL.
THE BALLOT LANGUAGE INCLUDE AN
ESTIMATE OF THE AMOUNT OF
PROPERTY TAX REQUIRED TO SERVICE
THAT BOUGHT.
CURRENTLY THAT ESTIMATE IS
EXPRESSED IN DOLLARS PER HUNDRED
DOLLARS OF ASSESSED VALUE
HOWEVER.
THE CURRENT AVERAGE PRICE OF A
HOME IN CALIFORNIA IS OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS SO IT
REQUIRES QUITE A BIT OF MATH ON
THE EVENT THE PART OF THE VOTER.
TO FIGURE OUT EXACTLY HOW MUCH
TAX THEY WOULD HAVE TO PAY TO
SERVICE THAT BOND THIS BILL AB
SIX TEN WOULD SIMPLY CHANGE THAT
REQUIREMENT. TO HAVE THE THE
SERVICE EXPRESSED IN DOLLARS PER
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT'S MUCH
EASIER TO DO THE MATH THERE THIS
BILL WILL IMPROVE VOTER
TRANSPARENCY IN A REQUEST AND I
VOTE ON A. B. SIX THEM.
THANK YOU MISTER OF AN AUSSIE
SAYING.
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
OUR GLOBAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
KIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
FIFTY SIX KNOWS.
TO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE THROUGH
SIXTY SIX PASS RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN AB
ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY?
QUICKLY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO HOUSING.
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB ONE
SIXTY IT ENSURES THE TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES WHICH ARE
SOME SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS
SACRED SITES WILL NOT BE
DESTROYED UNDER THE NEW
STREAMLINED HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
LAW.
WHAT'S A SACRED SITE IS LOST IT
COULD NEVER BE REPLACED
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE PROGRESS
TOWARDS PROTECTING AND
RESPECTING TRIBAL CULTURE
RESOURCES.
BY REQUIRING CONSULTATION WITH
TRIBES IN THE AREA OF A PROPOSED
PROJECT UNDERSEA QUIRK.
AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT WILL REQUIRE
THIS EXISTING CONSULTATION
STREAMLINED HOUSING APPROVALS SO
THAT THE POSSIBILITY OF
DESTROYING TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES CAN BE AVOIDED.
AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND UNANIMOUS
A UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I AFTER I
WROTE.
THANK YOU IS AGUIAR-CURRY.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ART OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTE
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM.
SIXTY EIGHT AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
NINE CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM AND ACTUALLY THE
HOUSING.
MR BELOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
I RISE NOW TO PRESENT AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY NINE A BILL THAT WILL
INCENTIVIZE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WITH A A COOL NEW
TOOL THAT WILL PERMIT NON PROFIT
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATIONS TO
SELL BONDS.
THAT OUR STATE INCOME TAX EXEMPT.
AND WITH THE THE BOND FUNDS
CREATE A PREDICTABLE AND STABLE
SOURCE OF FUNDS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THE EXEMPTION WILL ALLOW CITIES
LIKE THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES TO
CREATE SELF SUSTAINING LOCAL
HOUSING AGENCIES.
THAT USE MORTGAGE LOAN
REPAYMENTS TO FUND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS AND SUPPORT LOW
AND MIDDLE INCOME HOME BUYERS.
CITIES THAT DECIDE TO CREATE
THEIR OWN HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY
WILL BE INSULATED FROM FINANCIAL
RISK.
WE'VE SEEN SIMILAR NONPROFIT
AGENCIES FINANCE AGENCIES IN NEW
YORK AND RHODE ISLAND
SUCCESSFULLY FUND THOUSANDS OF
NEW HOMES.
SO AB SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE
PROVIDES A TOOL FOR CITIES TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING SHORTAGE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAME IS BLOOM SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
LOCAL OF MEMBERS OF RESERVE AT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FOLLOWED OF SIXTY NINE AB
TWO FORTY ONE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE OF
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
HEALING ARTS.
IS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY
BILL.
TWO FOUR ONE AB TWO FORTY ONE
WILL REDUCE DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH CARE BY REQUIRING
CONTINUED MEDICAL EDUCATION
COURSES TO INCLUDE CURRICULUM ON
IMPLICIT BIAS. FOR LICENSEES
UNDER THE MEDICAL BOARD
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT BOARD AND
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING.
IMPLICIT BIAS EXISTS WE ALL HAVE
IT.
BIAS OUR ATTITUDES OR
INTERNALIZE STEREO TYPES THAT
SUB CONSCIOUSLY AFFECT OUR
PERCEPTIONS ACTIONS AND
DECISIONS.
BUYERS OFTEN CONTRIBUTES TO
UNEQUAL TREATMENT OF PEOPLE
BASED ON RACE ETHNICITY GENDER
IDENTITY AGE SEXUAL ORIENTATION
DISABILITY AND OTHER%
CHARACTERISTICS.
IN HEALTH CARE IMPLICIT BIAS
PARTICULARLY CAN THREATEN THE
LIVES OF PATIENTS MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS CONSTANTLY MAKE
RAPID DECISIONS UNDER STRESSFUL
CONDITIONS THAT MAY ALTER THE
LIVES OF PATIENTS.
IMPLICIT BIAS IS IN THE NEWS
BECAUSE IT'S REAL.
BLACK WOMEN ARE THREE TO FOUR
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM
PREGNANCY OR CHILDBIRTH RELATED
CAUSES THAN WHITE WOMEN.
WOMEN ARE MORE LIKELY TO SURVIVE
A HEART ATTACK WHEN TREATED BY A
FEMALE PHYSICIAN. 18% OF PEOPLE
WHO IDENTIFY AS LESBIAN GAY
BISEXUAL TRANS ARE QUEER AVOID
DOCTORS OFFICES FOR FEAR OF
DISCRIMINATION AND PROVIDER BIAS
AND LATINO MEN IN CALIFORNIA ARE
21% LESS LIKELY TO RECEIVE THE
BEST TREATMENT FOR HIGH RISK
PROSTATE CANCER THAN WHITE MEN.
CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL COMMUNITY
SHOULD BE AT THE FOREFRONT TO
IMPROVE TREATMENT AND OUTCOMES
FOR PATIENTS WHO HAVE BEEN UNDER
SERVED BY THEIR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS.
AB TWO FOR ONE IS A CONSTRUCTIVE
BILL THAT WILL WORK TO KEEP
OTHER PEOPLE'S BIASES OUT OF
HEART HEALTH CARE.
ESPECIALLY AND ESPECIALLY AT
TIMES WHEN ONE'S LIFE IS AT RISK
OR AT STAKE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MS KAMLAGER-DOVE WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BACK. TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
NINE I BELIEVE -- THERE WAS A
PRESENTATION ON ON SEVENTY TIME
IS KAMLAGER-DOVE IF YOU COULD
PRESENT ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
SIXTY NINE WE WERE
.
DO YOU THINK MS CAM WATER DIVE
WE STAND CORRECTED WE HAD FILE
ITEM SIXTY NINE ON THE BOARD.
IN YOU PROPERLY PRESENTED ON
FILE ITEM.
SIXTY NINE THIS ITEM IS STILL
OPEN FOR DEBATE MISS WICKS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I WOULD A AS A
CO AUTHOR URGE YOU.
TO VOTE I FOR THIS YOU KNOW WE
ALL HAVE IMPLICIT BIAS EVERYONE
IN THIS ROOM AS IMPLICIT BIAS.
AND THE DIFFERENCE HERE IS MOST
OF US ARE NOT.
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS THAT
ALTHOUGH I KNOW.
WE DO HAVE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
HERE BUT IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH
IMPLICIT BIAS WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS THAT WE HAVE TO CREATE
PROGRAMS. TO ENDED.
AS THE AUTHOR STATED BLACK WOMEN
ARE THREE TO FOUR TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO DIE IN PREGNANCY
RELATED CAUSES.
ARE L. G. B. TO Q. FRIENDS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS EXPERIENCE
IMPLICIT BIAS IN HEALTH CARE.
THIS BILL AIMS TO FIX THIS
PROBLEM BY REQUIRING MORE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING. FOR
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS I WOULD
STRONGLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE AND
THANK YOU -- AUTHOR FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE ON THE BILL WITH YOU
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS WICKS SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MS KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU MAY CLOSE
YOU WISH.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE AND TELL
YOU ABOUT ICE [inaudible]
FIFTY NINE THOSE.
THREE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
NOW WE'RE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY AB TWO FORTY TWO CORRECT.
I SOME ABLE TO FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE
THAN OTHERS AND THAT FEELING TO
IMPLICIT BIAS.
THANK YOU MS CAM RW MAY GET OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
YOU SEE THERE'S A THEME HERE
TODAY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR TWO
REQUIRES ATTORNEYS AND JUDGES TO
PARTAKE IN CONTINUAL EDUCATION
ON IMPLICIT BIAS EVERY THREE
YEARS AND CORPS PERSONNEL EVERY
TWO YEARS.
IMPLICIT BIAS IS THE UNCONSCIOUS
AND UNINTENTIONAL MENTAL
SHORTCUT THAT HUMAN BEINGS CAN
DEVELOP AND IT AFFECTS ALL OF US
IT IS OFTEN SUBTLE ASSOCIATIONS
WE MAKE BETWEEN GROUPS OF PEOPLE
AND STEREOTYPES.
ABOUT THESE GROUPS.
DESPITE PEOPLE'S BEST INTENTIONS
INCLUDING THOSE THAT WE COME IN
CONTACT WITH IN THE COURTS
RESEARCHERS HAVE FOUND THAT
SUBJECTS CAN CONSCIOUSLY EMBRACE
IDEAS OF FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY.
AND YET ON TESTS THAT MEASURE
SUBCONSCIOUS TENDENCIES STILL
SHOW A STRONG PROPENSITY TO LEAN
ON STEREO TYPES TO FILL IN THE
BLANKS ABOUT PEOPLE THEY DON'T
KNOW.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT ATTORNEYS
JUDGES AND COURT PERSONNEL
RECEIVE TRAINING ON A ROUTINE
BASIS TO RECOGNIZE THEIR
IMPLICIT BIAS SEASON TAKES STEPS
TO COUNTER ACT THEIR UNCONSCIOUS
INFLUENCES.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU ENTER INTO A
COURT ROOM YOU'RE PUTTING YOUR
LIFE.
YOUR TRUST AND SOMETIMES YOUR
FUTURE IN THE HANDS OF THE
OFFICERS OF THE COURT AND WE
KNOW.
THAT THAT COURT ROOM SHOULD
CONTAIN MANY THINGS IT SHOULD
CONTAIN FAIRNESS IT SHOULD
CONTAIN DUE PROCESS AND IT
SHOULD CONTAIN JUSTICE BUT IT
SHOULD NOT CONTAIN BIAS.
THIS BILL WILL WORK TO ADDRESS
THAT MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A. B..
TWO FOUR TWO THANK YOU MISS
KAMLAGER-DOVE SAME NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
OUR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE ABOUT [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE.
TELL A VOTE I FIFTY NINE OH ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE IS AB
THREE NINETY ONE CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL AND
ACTUALLY TO RENTED VEHICLES.
MR VOEPEL YOU MAY OPEN MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT TO YOU AB THREE
NINETY ONE THAT ENABLES VEHICLE
RENTAL COMPANIES TO REPORT THEFT.
AS VEHICLES BECOME OVER DO
RATHER THAN BEING REQUIRED TO
WAIT FIVE DAYS AFTER THE VEHICLE
RETURN DATE VEHICLE THEFT IS
UNIQUE.
IN A SENSE THAT ANY WASTED TIME
IN REPORTING PROCESS ALLOWS THE
CRIMINAL TO GEOGRAPHICALLY
DISCONNECT FROM THE SCENE THAT
MEANS BEAT FEET.
OR BEAT TIRES.
MOTIVATION FOR AUTOMOBILE THEFT
IS HIGHER WHEN THERE'S A FIVE
DAY GRACE PERIOD GIVEN LEAVING
PLENTY OF TIME TO FLEE THE SCENE
TO DISMEMBER THE VEHICLE FOR THE
SALE.
WHEN FRAUD IS DISCOVERED IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS NOTIFIED
IMMEDIATELY RATHER THAN WAITING
UNTIL THE FIVE DAYS EXPIRE?
I KNOW THIS BILL THE FIVE DAY
WAITING PERIOD WILL BE MINIMIZED
TO FORTY EIGHT HOURS IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT PROPER PROCEDURES
ARE CONDUCTED TO ENSURE BOTH
SAFETY AND UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN
THE RENTAL CAR AGENCY IN THE
RENTER OF THE VEHICLE.
COLLEAGUES I ASK YOU TODAY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THAT SIMPLY
EXPEDITES AND IMPROVES THE
SYSTEM OF TRACKING DOWN STOLEN
COOK.
CARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CARPOOL
OF THE ROLE [inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
RESERVE AT ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIVER I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PAST RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY TWO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
THREE AB FIVE FORTY SEVEN CLERK
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FORTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO EMPLOYMENT.
THERE'S GONZALEZ YOU MAIL THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB FIVE FORTY
SEVEN WORKS TO CHANGE A CULTURAL
SECTION SEXUAL ASSAULT
HARASSMENT AND FEAR IN THE
JANITORIAL INDUSTRY.
THERE WAS A MOVIE THAT CAME OUT
A FEW YEARS AGO WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO ADDRESS IT WAS CALLED
RAPE ON THE NIGHT SHIFT.
AND IT SHOWED HOW JANITORS WHO
WORK LATE AT NIGHT BY THEMSELVES
IN BUILDINGS FACE -- THINGS WE
CAN ONLY IMAGINE ACTUALLY BEING
RAPED ON THE JOB BEING ASSAULTED
AND WE ADDED A TRAINING
COMPONENT IN A BILL A FEW YEARS
AGO TO ENSURE THAT THEY COULD BE
TRAINED NOT ONLY ABOUT.
THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF THEIR
SUPERVISOR BUT THEIR RIGHTS IF
THEY'RE ACTUALLY A WORKER WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS EXTEND THAT
AND SAY THAT TRAINING DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE DONE BY SOME ATTORNEY
THAT DOESN'T SPEAK THE LANGUAGE
WONDER SEE IN THE CULTURE OF THE
JANITORS.
IT ALLOWS THE JANITORS
THEMSELVES TO BE TRAINED TO BE
PEER EDUCATORS SO THAT THE
TRAINING MAKES THE MOST AMOUNT
OF SENSE FOR THESE WORKERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
[inaudible]
GLOBAL [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF IT AT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRED OF THE CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE.
FIFTY ONE KNOWS EIGHT THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY FOUR IS AB FIVE SIXTY
MISTER SANTIAGO CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIXTY BY
SOMETHING MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY UNION ORGANIZING MR
SANTIAGO YOU MAIL.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB FIVE SIXTY WILL
ENSURE THAT THE RATE PAYER
DOLLARS ARE NOT USED BY
UTILITIES THE FAVOR OR OPPOSE.
A UNION ACTIVITIES THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS BY PART IN
SUPPORT -- AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
[inaudible]
QUIRK LIBERAL.
DESIRE BUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY THREE KNOWS.
FOR THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY FIVE THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILES TO TAKE OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTY FIVE AB.
SEVENTEEN NINETY FIVE CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY NINETY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF AND ACTUALLY
THE SELECTIONS.
IS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
NINETY FIVE REQUIRES LANDLORDS
IF THEY SEEK TO DISPLACE THE
TENANT OR LEASE SEE UNDER THE
ALICE ACT. TO PROHIBIT ACCESS TO
THE UNLAWFUL DETAINER ACTION
RECORDS AND REQUIRE THE LANDLORD
TO IDENTIFY THE TYPE OF UNLAWFUL
DETAINER ACTION IN THE CAPTION
OF THE LANDLORDS COMPLAINT.
THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE
TENANTS MOVED OUT -- THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
AND THAT EVICTION STAYS ON THEIR
CREDIT REPORT FOR SEVEN YEARS
THIS IS NOT GOOD FOR TENANTS IT
IS NOT GOOD FOR LANDLORDS AB
SEVENTY NINETY FIVE WOULD ENSURE
THAT WHEN A LANDLORD HAS ELECTED.
TO EVICT A TENANT UNDER THE
ALICE ACT THAT A PUBLIC
OBJECTION RECORD DOES NOT
UNFAIRLY PENALIZE THOSE TENANTS.
A RECORD OF THE FICTION EVEN IF
THE EVICTION IS BASED ON A
REASON THAT IS NOT THE FAULT OF
THE TENANT MAKES IT DRASTICALLY
HARDER. FOR TENANTS TO FIND
FUTURE HOUSING.
AND LANDLORDS UTILIZED TENANT
SCREENING SERVICES SUCH AS
CREDIT REPORTS TO EVALUATE
PROSPECTIVE TENANTS.
REGISTRIES DO NOT EXPLAIN THE
REASON THAT A TENANT WAS EVICTED.
AB SEVENTY NINETY FIVE WILL
PROTECT THE TENANT REPUTATION BY
REQUIRING OWNERS TO SPECIFY THE
TYPE OF UNLAWFUL DETAINER ACTION
IN THE CAPTION OF THE OWNER
CIVIL COMPLAINT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARABLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
.
THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE MOVES A CALL
THE BRIDGE BACK IN REGULAR FILE
ORDER.
WE'RE AT FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY NINE A. B..
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE QUICKLY.
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN EIGHTY ONE
BY SOME REMEMBER THE MON AND
ACTUALLY TO CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS.
MISS LAMAR EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE ENSURES THAT
ALL CHARITIES REPORTING GIFT IN
KIND DONATIONS TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S REGISTRY OF CHARITABLE
TRUST.
DO SO UNDER THE SAME UNIFORM
TRANSPARENT RULES THIS BILL HAS
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS Là C. NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN.
PRESENT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROTELLA VOTE I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY AB.
TWELVE OH NINE COOPERATE.
AS I'M ABLE TO ALTHOUGH NINE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER DESIRING
ANOTHER'S AND ACTUALLY TO
INSURANCE MISTER NAZARIAN EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A. B
TWELVE OH NINE ENSURE IS THAT
CONSUMERS WHO HAVE A LIFE
INSURANCE POLICY WITH LONG TERM
CARE BENEFITS HAVE A RIGHT TO
ACCESS LOAN.
AND WITHDRAWAL FEATURES OF THEIR
POLICY WHILE ALSO RECEIVING LONG
TERM CARE BENEFITS THE BILL ALSO
PROHIBITS LONG TERM CARE RATES
THAT INCREASE BASED.
ON THE AGE OF THE INSURED A. B.
TWELVE OR NINE IS SPONSORED BY
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
I WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THE COMMISSION IS AREA AND WITH
THAT CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROUND ROLL TELEVOTE I
SEVENTY NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM.
EIGHTY ONE AB TWELVE TWENTY SIX
COREY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TOLD TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE HIGHWAYS.
MR HOLDEN HE MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A
CALIFORNIA IS FACING A CRIPPLING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SHORTAGE.
IT HAS THE LARGEST POPULATION ON
SHELTER PEOPLE IN THE NATION.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS RAPID
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR STATE WE
MUST RETHINK THE SPACE AVAILABLE
TO US IN HEAVILY POPULATED AREAS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWENTY SIX
WILL STUDY THE FEASIBILITY OF
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING OVER BELOW
GRADE HIGHWAYS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
OUR GLOBAL ROLE [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE RESERVE LOW
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLES HOWEVER I AS FIFTY
EIGHT KNOWS TO THAT MEASURE
PASSES WERE FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY TWO AB TWELVE SIXTY SIX
CROCKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SIXTY SIX
BY FAMILY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
AND ACTUALLY TO VEHICLES.
HISTORY THIS YOU MAIL BUT THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER US IN THE
BILL TWELVE SIXTY SIX SIX TO
PROMOTE BIKE SAFETY IN GUIDANCE
ON OUR ROADS.
THIS LEGISLATION IS BASED ON A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CITY
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS IN
ENCOURAGING THE CREATION OF
SHARED BIKE AND RIGHT -- LINES
LAYS THAT DIRECT DRIVERS AND
CYCLISTS ON SAFE PASSAGE THROUGH
INTERSECTION.
SO CERTAINLY THIS BILL WOULD
CLARIFY THAT THIS SHARED A BIKE
IN RIGHT -- THE TERM AND CONCEPT
IS LEGAL AND REQUIRES CAL TENDS.
TO THE DEVELOP AND ADOPT SUCH
GUIDELINES.
THANK YOU MISS RIVAS SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE [inaudible]
COR CLUB [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ADDED LOW
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU WHAT I SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM. EIGHTY THREE PASS
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY FOUR A. B..
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT ASSEMBLY WILL
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT BY STANLEY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM AND ACTUALLY
THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
THIRTEEN NO DAY THIRTEEN OH
EIGHT WOULD ALLOW QUALIFIED
STUDENTS TO TASTE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES.
IF THE ACADEMIC INSTITUTION HAS
ESTABLISHED AN ASSOCIATE'S
DEGREE OR A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
PROGRAM IN HOTEL MANAGEMENT OR
CULINARY ARTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLARK WELL.
OVER THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
FOUR KNOWS TO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE IS
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
AND ACTUALLY THE FOSTER CHILDREN
THE SHOW OF EMAIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER CALIFORNIA LAW ALREADY
REQUIRES THAT LEGAL SERVICES BE
PROVIDED TO UNDOCUMENTED
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS WHO WERE
TAKEN INTO CUSTODY BY THE OFFICE
OF REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT.
THIS BILL -- EXTENDS THOSE LEGAL
SERVICES TO CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE.
AND ASK FOR A VOTE.
THERE IS LEVINE SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THEM.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE
VOTE ICE FIFTY THREE KNOWS.
TEN THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS EIGHTY SIX AND EIGHTY
SEVEN PASS RETAIN. FOUR FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
FOUR CORKERY.
AS LEGAL FIFTEEN SIXTY FOUR BY
FAMILY MEMBER BERMAN AND I PLAN
CONSUMER PRIVACY.
MR BERMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT A COVERED
BUSINESS IS REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
A TOLL FREE PHONE NUMBER FOR
CONSUMERS. TO MAKE ACCESS AND
DELETION REQUESTS GIVEN THE
POTENTIAL LEGAL LIABILITY FROM
PROPER DISCLOSURES OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR BUSINESSES
TO MAINTAIN PROPER DOCUMENTATION
OF THEIR QUEST THE VERIFICATION
PROCESS AND THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED IN RESPONSE.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY FOUR WOULD
ALLOW A BUSINESS COVERED BY THE
CCP A TO MAINTAIN EITHER A TOLL
FREE PHONE NUMBER OR AN EMAIL
ADDRESS.
IN THE PHYSICAL ADDRESS FOR
CONSUMERS TO EXERCISE THEIR
RIGHTS UNDER THE CPA.
A BUSINESS THAT OPERATES
EXCLUSIVELY ONLINE WOULD BE
EXEMPT FROM THE REQUIREMENT TO
PROVIDE A PHYSICAL ADDRESS IN
ADDITION TO AN EMAIL ADDRESS.
THIS FLEXIBILITY WOULD ALLOW
BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE AN OPTION
THAT FITS THE CONTEXT OF THE
CONSUMER BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP.
MEETING HOW THE CONSUMER ENGAGES
WITH THE BUSINESS GENERALLY AND
WORK WITHIN THE BEST PRACTICES
TO VERIFYING RESPOND TO REQUESTS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CAR CLUB THE ROLE.
RESERVE THAT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS THERE A VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLLED OUT OF OUT AYE
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE IS
AB.
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT CORKERY.
A SOME ABLE SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
BY SOME THE MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
AND ACTUALLY DEPARTMENTAL
JUSTICE.
SURE RIVAS YOU MAY GET OPEN.
MISTER SPEAKER ONCE AGAIN -- I
RISE HERE TODAY TO INTRODUCE
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIXTY TWENTY EIGHT SO LAST YEAR
TWENTY GENERAL HOBBY ERR.
THE BEST SERRA ESTABLISHED THE
BUREAU OF ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
NOW THIS BILL SIXTY TWENTY EIGHT
IT DOES TWO THINGS FIRST IT WILL
INCLUDE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
THIS NEWLY ESTABLISHED BUREAU
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. TO THE
LIST OF AGENCIES THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH MUST COORDINATE
WITH REGARDING THIS STATES A
VIRAL JUSTICE PROGRAMS.
AND SECOND IT EXPANDS THE
DEFINITION OF A VIRAL JUSTICE.
TO INCLUDE THE MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT OF IMPACTED
[inaudible]
THE COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE THEIR
INVOLVEMENT IN THE DECISIONS
THAT IMPACT THEIR HEALTH AND
SAFETY SO WITH THAT -- THAT THEY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A SPEAKER.
WELL THE BEST RIVAS SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS THAT IT IS
ACTIVE OF ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A
NICE.
FIFTY KNOWS FOURTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM NINETY
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN
CORPORATION.
AS A LEGAL SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AND I PLAN TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THIS CAN SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ABOUT
OF SIX YEARS AGO AND NUMBER OF
US VOTED ON A HISTORIC BILL ON
THIS FLOOR TO INSURE THROUGH AB
SIXTY LICENSES THAT FOLKS WHO --
WHERE OTHERWISE UNDOCUMENTED
COULD COULD BECOME SAFE DRIVERS
THAT THEY COULD BE LICENSED
DRIVERS IN WE PASS THAT BILL WE
PROMISED THEM THAT IN FACT THAT
INFORMATION WOULD STAY
CONFIDENTIAL THAT NOBODY WOULD
BE ABLE TO ACCESS THAT
INFORMATION?
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENED IT SEEMS
THAT WE DIDN'T QUITE ANTICIPATE
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL NOW IT SEEMS
THERE'S A LOOPHOLE WHERE ICE CAN
ACTUALLY ACCESS THAT INFORMATION
THROUGH A STATEWIDE DATABASE --
THAT IS RUN BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
SIMPLY SAY THAT THE ONLY WAY I
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS IT IS
IF THEY HAVE A WARRANT.
ANOTHER WHERE WORDS IF THERE IS
THAT ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
BROKEN THE LAW WHO HAVE AN
ACTIVE WARRANT THEY CAN'T IMPACT --
IN AND ACCESS THE DATABASE TO
FIND OUT WHERE THAT PERSON LIVES
WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE AND WHERE TO
FIND THEM HOWEVER IF THEY DON'T
HAVE -- A CRIME THAT'S BEEN
COMMITTED AND THEY DON'T HAVE AN
ACTIVE WARRANT THAT THAT THAT
CANNOT BE DONE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF WHAT IS OUT OF OF
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
EYES FIFTY THREE KNOWS.
FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
FOLLOW NINETY ONE IS AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY -- SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT BY SOMETHING MEMBER
CARILLO AND ACTUALLY PREVAILING
WAGE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S AN
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT A BILL THAT WILL ENSURE
WORKERS ARE PAID FAIRLY. FOR
THEIR WORK BY PROVIDING CLARITY
AS TO WHEN THE PREVAILING WAGE
IS REQUIRED I'M PRETTY
CONSTRUCTION SERVICES WELL STATE
LAW MAKES IT CLEAR THAT PRE
CONSTRUCTION PHASES OF A PROJECT
FALL UNDER THE DEFINITION OF
PUBLIC WORKS.
AND THAT'S REQUIRE THE PAYMENT A
PREVAILING WAGE THE AMBIGUITY AS
TO WHAT IS CONSIDERED PRE
CONSTRUCTION WORK HAS LED TO
CONFUSION AMONG STAKEHOLDERS.
IN THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AS
TO WHEN PREVAILING WAGE
REQUIREMENTS ACTUALLY APPLY.
IN AN EFFORT TO ENSURE WORKERS
IN THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY ARE
RECEIVING THE PREVAILING WAGE
THEY DESERVE AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
ABLE CLARIFY THAT PRE
CONSTRUCTION AS IT RELATES TO
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS.
ALSO INCLUDE SITE ASSESSMENTS
AND FEASIBILITY STUDIES.
BOTH OF WHICH ARE CRUCIAL TO A
PROJECT'S SUCCESS.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
DAVIS CREEL SAYING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
SARAH VOTE ON MEMBERS OF DESIRE
TO THE ALL MEMBER SERVICE ERA
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
KNOWS.
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS NINETY TWO OR NINETY
THREE PASS RETAIN.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM.
NINETY FOUR AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
THREE BY MR CHIU QUICKLY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SIXTY
THREE BY SOMETHING MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND ACTUALLY THE HOUSING.
IS YOUR SHOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES IN THE MIDST OF OUR
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE WOULD%
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DENSITY
BONUSES 41100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS.
SINCE EXISTING ZONING IS OFTEN
TOO LOW FOR AFFORDABLE PROJECTS
TO PENCIL OUT MORE DENSITY CAN
MAKE PROJECTS FINANCIALLY
FEASIBLE AND SINCE HOUSING
FUNDING AS SCARCE THIS BILL WILL
STRETCH FUNDING TO BUILD MORE
UNITS.
I WANT TO THANK THE STRONG
IPARTISAN VOTES THROUGH THREE
COMMITTEES WITHOUT ANY NO VOTES
AND AFTER I BOUGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOOSE SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHOSE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND TELL
THE VOTE I SIXTY NINE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS NINETY FIVE AND NINETY SIX
PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN IS AB
FIVE ONE SIX CROCKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIXTEEN BY
SOME THE MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND
OTHERS AN EXCELLENT VEHICLES.
MR CHIU YOU MAKE IT OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB
FIVE SIXTEEN WOULD REFORM A FEW
TOWING PRACTICES THAT HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
THERE ARE MANY GOOD REASONS WHY
CAR SHOULD BE TOWED FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY IN TRAFFIC FLOW THIS BILL
DOES NOT TOUCH TWO DOZEN LEGAL
REASONS TO TOW CARS.
BUT THERE ARE THREE TOWING
GROUNDS THAT ARE NOT RELATED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY IN TRAFFIC.
THAT PENALIZE CALIFORNIANS
BECAUSE OF INCOME TOES WHEN YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO PAY A
NUMBER PARKING TICKETS.
AND HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO PAY
OUTDATED CAR REGISTRATION OR
CAN'T PAY FOR A PRIVATE PARKING
SPOT AND OF LEGALLY PARKED FOR
OVER THREE DAYS IN A PUBLIC
STREET.
IF YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY
PARKING TICKETS ARE CAR
REGISTRATION YOU CAN'T AFFORD
THE AVERAGE FEES TO GET YOUR
CARS OF THE TOW YARD.
GETTING TOWED MEANS THAT YOU
LOSE YOUR CAR YOU CAN'T GET TO
YOUR JOB YOU COULD LOSE YOUR JOB
WHICH MEANS YOU CAN'T PAY THE
DEBT THAT THE WAS WAS THE REASON
FOR THE TOW.
OR CAR OWNER IS NOT THE ONLY
PARTY WHO LOSES TOW YARD TO
REQUIRED TO PAY FOR THE EXPENSES
OF STEALING CARS FOR THIRTY DAYS
BEFORE SELLING AT AN AUCTION.
THE AVERAGE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR COST OF STORAGE AND LEAN
SALES EXCEED THE AVERAGE SALES
PRICE OF A CAR SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
AND CITIES RAIN TORN PROGRAMS IS
MONEY FOR THE SAME REASON
TYPICALLY LOSING OVER TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CAR TOWED.
IN THIS SITUATION LOW INCOME
PEOPLE LOSE TôI ARTS LOSE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LOSE OUR BILL
WOULD AND THE CYCLE POVERTY
THAT'S NOT WORKING FOR ANYONE.
I APPRECIATE THE STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT INTO
COMMITTEES AND NOTE NO VOTES AND
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CLARK LOCAL THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLES HOW
IT ABOUT AYE AYES.
FORTY FOUR KNOWS FIVE THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NINETY EIGHT PASS
RETAIN.
WE'VE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
[inaudible] NINETY NINE WE'RE
FILE ITEM.
ONE HUNDRED AC ARE EIGHTY FIVE
COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT LUCIEN
EIGHTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
RAMADAN.
IS REYES YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT A C.
R..
EIGHTY FIVE A RESOLUTION THAT
ACKNOWLEDGES THE MUSLIM HOLY
MONTH OF RAMADAN.
AND EXPRESSES THE LEGISLATURE'S
RESPECT TO MUSLIMS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
RAMADAN IS A TIME FOR REFLECTION
AND SPIRITUAL DISCIPLINE WHEN
I'M MUSLIMS EXPRESS OUR DEVOTION
TO FAITH.
FAMILY AND SERVICE.
IN FACT THERE ARE MANY STAFFERS
IN OUR STATE CAPITOL WHO ARE
TAKING PART IN THE FASTING OF
RAMADAN.
THE MUSLIM AMERICAN COMMUNITY
CONTINUES TO BE A PILLAR OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSITY.
ENCOMPASSING NEARLY EVERY ETHNIC
GROUP OF OUR STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE RELIGIOUS
COMMUNITIES AND BODY ARE
INHERENT VALUES AS A STATE AND
AS A COUNTRY.
AS DOES OUR COMMITMENT TO
RESPECT EQUALITY AND PEACE AMONG
CULTURES.
IT HAS BEEN A DIFFICULT YEAR FOR
THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY IN OUR
STATE AND INTERNATIONALLY AS
ACTS OF HATE AND VIOLENCE HAVE
OCCURRED IN THE VERY SPACES.
THAT ARE SOON TO BE SAFE. FOR
THIS RAMADAN LET US NOT ONLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS IMPORTANT
HOLIDAY.
BUT SAY TO OUR MUSLIMFRIENDS
NEIGHBORS AND CONSTITUENTS.
WE STAND WITH YOU AGAINST
ISLAMOPHOBIA AND HATRED.
AND WILL DEFEND YOUR RIGHTS TO
WORSHIP AND BE SAFE IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES [inaudible]
TOMORROW EVENING.
BEGINNING AT SEVEN PM IN THE
EUREKA ROOM OF THE CAPITOL
BASEMENT WILL BE THE SIXTEENTH
ANNUAL CAPITAL IFTAR DINNER.
I INVITE YOU ALL TO ATTEND THIS
ANNUAL EVENT. TO STAND IN UNITY
WITH THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY.
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ON A C. R..
EIGHTY FIVE SO THAT WE CAN
COLLECTIVELY WHICH ARE MUSLIM
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS A BLESSED
RAMADAN.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THEY DO REQUEST OF THE
FIRST ROLL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MS REYES.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE RESOLUTION YES MR GABRIEL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF A C. R..
EIGHTY FIVE I AM WANT TO THANK
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SEA AMBER TO
DO YOU KNOW FOR ME FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IS
PROUD.
TO STUDENT SUPPORT AND EXTEND
OUR WARMEST WISHES AND GREETINGS
TO THE MUSLIM AMERICAN.
COMMUNITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO WISH THEM
BLESSINGS DURING THE HOLY MONTH
OF RAMADAN.
MEMBERS OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS
WERE HONORED TO MEET WITH
LEADERS IN THE MOST AMERICAN
COMMUNITY DURING OUR JEWISH
CAUCUS RETREAT EARLIER THIS YEAR
IN LOS ANGELES.
WHO TO TALK TO THEM ABOUT ISSUES
WHERE WE SHARE VALUES IN COMMON
ONE WORK TOGETHER ON SO CIVIL
RIGHTS AND SOCIAL JUSTICE ON
FIGHTING DISCRIMINATION AND
BIGOTRY IN OUR SOCIETY?
AND WE'RE GOING TO CREATE A MORE
PEACEFUL AND EQUITABLE WORLD.
AND SO WE WANT TO WISH THE
MUSCLE AMERICAN COMMUNITY A
RAMADAN MUBARAK A SAFE AND
PEACEFUL AND HAPPY MONTH OF
RAMADAN AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THIS AYE VOTE ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S CAUCUS.
THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL MISTER
KANSEN CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SAM
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF A C. R.
EIGHTY FIVE WHICH RECOGNIZED TO
MOSUL IN HOLY MONTH OF RAMADAN.
ALMOST A QUARTER OF OUR WORLD'S
POPULATION THIS MOTION.
AND EIGHT A LARGE PERCENT OF THE
MARCH OF IN THE ASIAN COUNTRIES
M. IN MY DISTRICT AND THROUGH
ALL CALIFORNIA MUSLIMS ARE.
PART OF THE FABRIC OF OUR
DIVERSE ETHNIC COMMUNITY.
AND THIS MONTH IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF HIS FAITH AND IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT EXPRESS
GROWTH IF YOU AND EIGHT THOSE IN
NEED.
THE COMPASSION AND RESPECT
ILLUSTRATE THIS RULE ALL RAMADAN
SERVE AS A REMINDER FOR ALL OF
US TO CONTINUE BUILT AND SUPPORT
ONE ANOTHER ACROSS.
ALL FAITH AND SPEAK AGAINST
THREATS TO RELIGIOUS FREEDOM.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORT OF AC
ARE.
EIGHTY FIVE IN ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF
THIS TIME OF SPIRITUAL RENEWAL
OR OF OUR MUSLIM COMMUNITY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU.
DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES MATT
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO
RISE UP IN SUPPORT OF A C. R.
EIGHTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
RAMADAN FOR THIS OBSERVANCE OF
RAMADAN HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND
AROUND THE WORLD.
WE EXTEND OUR BEST WISHES TO OUR
MOVE SOME BROTHERS AND SISTERS
AND SAY TO THEM HAPPY RAMADAN.
LIKE SO MANY PEOPLE WE VIEW
HOLIDAYS THROUGH THE EYES OF
OTHERS AND CLEARLY WE SEE THE
THROUGH THE EYES OF OUR MUSLIM
BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
THE FESTIVE TIME OF RAMADAN TIME
A FAMILY GATHERING MEALS AT A
SHARED.
A WERE A FOCUS UPON THE
PRINCIPLES OF JUSTICE IN IT AND
PROGRESS IN TOLERANCE AND
DIGNITY FOR HUMAN BEINGS.
WE RECOGNIZE THE TREMENDOUS
ATTACKS ON MUSLIMS AROUND THE
WORLD.
AND THIS A LOT AND WE THEREFORE
IDENTIFY WITH OFTENTIMES THE
FACT THAT THEY ARE OFTEN JUDGED
TO BE PEOPLE THAT THEY'RE NOT IN
THERE PEACEFUL.
THE PEOPLE WHO LOVE LIFE WHO
LOVE OTHERS AND RESPECT OTHER
RELIGIONS.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH LIKE SO
MANY AFRICAN AMERICANS MUSLIMS
CAME TO THIS COUNTRY -- IN IN
SLAVE SHIPS 15215% OF ALL THE
SLAVES BROUGHT TO THIS COUNTRY
WERE PRACTICING OF THE MUSLIM
RELIGION.
AND WHEN YOU TRAVEL TO AFRICA
YOU SEE MUSLIM TEMPLES
EVERYWHERE AND THE BELIEF.
THAT THEY CELEBRATE THAT AS WELL
AS TRADITIONAL AFRICAN RELIGIONS
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT
THERE ONE POINT SIX BILLION
MUSLIMS WORLDWIDE IN AND
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION.
OF THE MUSLIM AMERICANS WITH
DIVERSE ETHNIC AND CULTURAL
BACKGROUNDS IT'S INTERESTING
THAT WE HAVE AN IMAGE OF WILL
MOST LIMIT AS AND I WAS RIDING
HOME THE LAST NIGHT OF ONE OF
OUR SERGEANTS PICKED ME UP.
AND WE BEGAN TO TALK ABOUT
RAMADAN AND THE CHALLENGES OF
RUM DOT AND I HAD ME LAUGHING
ABOUTA GIRLFRIEND OF MINE WHOSE
HUSBAND IS MUSLIM.
AND SHE WAS TRYING TO HELP HIM
WITH RAMADAN AND SHE WAS SO
ANGRY BECAUSE SHE WOKE UP WHEN
THE SUN WAS UP WHICH MEANT SHE
WAS NOT GOING TO EAT FOR THE
WHOLE DAY SO WE WERE LAUGHING
ABOUT THAT.
AND HE TOLD ME AT THAT TIME HOW
HE WAS MUSLIM I HAD NO IDEA AND
AND HIS CHALLENGE DURING RAMADAN
AND HOW.
HE STOOD IN THE BACK OF THE
FLOOR HERE IN ALMOST PASSED OUT
THE FIRST DAY BECAUSE OF HIS
DESIRE FOR CAFFEINE.
AND SO I WAS REALLY QUITE
INTERESTING THAT THIS REALLY
BRINGS TO BEAR THAT YOU HAVE NO
IDEA WHO YOU'RE SITTING NEXT TO
WHO YOU'RE TALKING TO THEY'RE
ALL REALLY ONE PEOPLE.
AND IT WAS REALLY QUITE
INTERESTING AS WE AS WE LAUGHED
AS I'M HE TOLD ME HOME LAST
NIGHT ABOUT THE CHALLENGES WE
ALL FACE AND THE FACT THAT WE'RE
REALLY ALL.
ONE AND THAT HE IS DEALING WITH
RAMADAN AND SO HAPPY TO BE ABLE
TO DEAL WITH THAT SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
THAT WE DO SUPPORT A C. R.
EIGHTY FIVE AND SAY ALL OF OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS HAPPY
RAMADAN.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM IS RACES ASKING THAT
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
LOCAL ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR.
EIGHTY FIVE CO AUTHORS ADDING ON
THE RESOLUTION [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SEVENTY TWO CO
AUTHORS ADDED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE.
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM ONE ON
ONE ACR.
NINETY THREE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CAN CARESS LUCIEN
NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN RELATIVE TO CITRUS DRY DAY --
ONE ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
MEMBERS ACR NINETY THREE
ACKNOWLEDGES THE EFFORTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CITRUS INDUSTRY AND
COMBAT AND FOOD AND SECURITY.
BY RECOGNIZING MAY FIFTEENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN AS CITRUS FRIDAY
AT THE STATE CAPITOL.
THIS WEDNESDAY'S CITRUS MUTUAL
WILL BE HOSTING THE SECOND
ANNUAL CITRUS STRIDE AROUND
CAPITOL PARK FOR EVERY
REGISTERED PARTICIPANT A
THOUSAND POUNDS OF CITRUS WILL
BE DONATED TO THE FARM TO FAMILY
PROGRAM.
THE FARM TO FAMILY PROGRAM LAST
YEAR OVER THIRTY THOUSAND POUNDS
OF FRESH CITRUS WERE DONATED TO
THOSE AFFECTED BY FOOD AND
SECURITY.
I HOPE TO SEE ALL OF YOU AND
YOUR STAFF AT THE CITRUS TRIED
THIS WEDNESDAY ON THE EAST LAWN
OF THE CAPITOL AT NOON.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN APPRECIATING
THE EFFORTS OF OUR CITRUS
GROWERS AND OUR AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION ON THE
RESOLUTION IS OR WHAT WOULD YOU
LIKE FOR US ROLE OPEN FOR CALL
AUTHORS.
MEMBERS WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE
FOR BOTH IN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
YES IS FOR CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SEVENTY TWO CO
AUTHORS AT A WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS PREPARE TO LIFT THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM.
THIRTY FIVE AB.
SEVENTEEN NINETY FIVE QUIRK OF
POSTS.
ALL MEMBERS TO DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE TALLIED
ABOUT EYES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE KNOWS.
NINETEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE.
WELL I WANTED TO S. J. R. TO HER
CAREER.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION TWO BY
SENATOR UMBERG AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO THE PRESIDENT'S
NATIONAL EMERGENCY DECLARATION.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT AS J. R..
TO ON FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE PRESIDENT
THE CURRENT NATIONAL EMERGENCY
AT THE BORDER AND ANNOUNCED HIS
INTENTIONS TO DIVERT BILLIONS OF
FEDERAL.
FUNDS FOR MILITARY CONSTRUCTION
FUNDING MILITARY FAMILY FUNDING
AND COUNTER NARCOTICS OPERATIONS.
DIVERTING THESE FUND ORIGINALLY
INTENDED FOR MILITARY
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS AND
COUNTER DRUG ACTIVITIES IN
CALIFORNIA COMES AT THE EXPENSE
OF TROOP READINESS.
AND DEPARTMENT WIDE EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE MILITARY'S AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IS AFFECTS US ALL OVER THE STATE.
THE FUNDS THAT WERE NOT DIVERTED
WOULD HAVE BEEN USED FOR
CONSTRUCTING A NEW NAVY SEAL
BASE IN CORONADO.
UPDATING A US NAVAL WEAPONS
STATION SEAL BEACH CONSTRUCTING
A NEW HANGAR AT TRAVIS AIRFORCE
BASE IN FAIRFIELD.
FUNDING AC ONE THIRTY FLIGHT
SIMULATOR IN OXNARD CALIFORNIA.
I KNOW MY OWN DISTRICT
RENOVATING A DEFENSE
DISTRIBUTION CENTER.
ALSO TAKING CARE OF OUR SOLDIERS
AS WE UPDATE OUR HOSPITAL.
ORGANIZATIONS AND WE ALL KNOW
THERE'S AN OVERDOSE EPIDEMIC
OCCURRING IN THIS COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW AND WHILE THERE IS A TASK
FORCE PUT TOGETHER NONE OF THAT
MONEY IS GOING TOWARDS -- WHAT
THIS FUNDING IS GOING?
FOR WE SHOULD SEND A VERY STRONG
MESSAGE TO REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS ALIKE THAT THIS
DIVERSION OF FUNDS.
IS NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
CALIFORNIANS OR THE UNITED
STATES.
THIS RESOLUTION URGES THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS TO STAND IN
UNITY AND BLOCK THE PRESIDENT'S
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
DECLARATION BY OVERRIDING A
PRESIDENT'S VETO OF HOUSE JOINT
RESOLUTION. FORTY SIX TWENTY
NINETEEN MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE WE ALL STAND UP HERE
AND RAISE OUR HAND TO PROTECT
AND DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF
UNITED STATES IN THE
CONSTITUTION OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE APPROACH
YOU EXPROPRIATION OF FUNDING
COMES AT CONGRESS NOT DIRECTLY
TO THE PRESIDENT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
DOCTOR CHOI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS.
OF THIS SAW ASSEMBLY I STAND.
TODAY WITH A VERY HEAVY HEART.
IN OPPOSITION OF ALL SCA ARE.
TO COLLEAGUES.
I FEAR THAT THIS RESOLUTION IS --
SETTING YEAH.
AND OF THE PARTISAN FIGHT.
ON A NATIONAL ISSUE IN THIS
CHAMBER.
THIS RESOLUTION IS -- DECLARING.
UP.
OPPOSITION. TO A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY DECLARATION.
WHICH WAS SOME MAY TO GAIN.
FUNDS TO TO BUILD THE WALL. TO
THE COUNTRY IS SO SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THIS A DECLARATION WAS A MADE IN
THE FACE OF THE MILLIONS OF ALL.
IMMIGRANTS CROSSING THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY. TO ENTER THIS COUNTRY.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THIS BODY TO
DEBATE THE NATIONAL ISSUES.
LOOK AT THE AGENDA TODAY.
AND WE HAVE A MILLIONS
[inaudible]
THOUSANDS LITERALLY.
MANY MANY PROBLEMS ARE HERE.
THAT THE NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
THE WITHIN OUR OWN STATE.
WE HAVE A SO MANY BEERS -- TO
CONSIDER.
EVEN NOT AT THIS MOMENT.
UNLIKE THE A. C. R. SEVENTY FOUR
AND THE A. C. OUT. EIGHTY FIVE
I'M AFRAID THAT THIS RESOLUTION
WILL CALL SUCH A DEVICE.
WITH OUR STATE AND OUR COUNTRY.
WHEN ABOVE ALL ELSE?
WE SHOULD BE ARE WORKING TO
UNIFIED THIS STATE.
AND THE NATION.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THIS
RESOLUTION NOT WILL REFLECT.
THE REAL ISSUE IS A FACING THIS
STATE.
AND THEN I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
THE IT IS -- THIS STATE SO
RESPONSIBILITY. TO FIGHT THE
CONGRESSIONAL ISSUES.
IT IS SO FOR THOSE REASONS SO
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK BEFORE
YOUR NO FAULT.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE S. JAY ARE DR EGGMAN.
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH AND
WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
YES DESPITE MY COLLEAGUES HEAVY
HEART -- I CONTINUE TO ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE BECAUSE IT VERY
MUCH IS AN ISSUE FOR CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THIS FUNDING IS BEING
DIVERTED FROM OUR STATE.
FROM OUR SOLDIERS FROM OUR
COMMUNITIES [inaudible] FOR TO
TO IMPOSE EMINENT DOMAIN WHICH
AS FAR AS I'VE ALWAYS KNOWN IS
NOT BEEN.
AT THE TOP END OF THE OF MY
COLLEAGUES A PRIORITIES SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE SEND
A MESSAGE WHICH THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS WE DO WE SEND
MESSAGES.
THAT THE FUNDING THAT WAS
APPROPRIATED FOR OUR STATE SHE
CONTINUE TO COME TO OUR STATE.
IN CARE OF OUR SOLDIERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE ABOUT.
MEMBERS THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON AS J.
R..
TO CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE.
THERE ARE FIFTY FOUR CO AUTHORS
ADDED.
AND THIS IS AN ASHTRAY ARE
REQUIRES A ROLL CALL VOTE CIRCLE
OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OUT OF THEM ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS.
THIRTEEN RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
I WAS REMOVING THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER WISH
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK READ THE SECOND I CAN TAKE
OUR ASSEMBLY BILL TEN EIGHTY
THREE BY SOMETHING MEMBER BURKE
AND ACTUALLY TO ENERGY.
BURKE WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE ROTELLA VOTE.
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIXTEEN I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO AS LEGAL
NINE FIFTY SIX I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO SENATE BILL FIFTEEN
THIRTEEN I SEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY HI SEVENTY TWO
NO ZERO AND ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY EIGHT EYES
SEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO MEMBERS MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY MAY FOURTEENTH CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY MAY FIFTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY MAY
SIXTEENTH.
FLOOR SESSION IS A NINE AM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED GERMAN TO MEMORY.
MEMBERS A QUORUM CALL IS LEFT IN.
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED.
REMAINING MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS.
AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES
WILL BE A TURNING AND THE MEMORY
.
FOR MANY MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
[inaudible]
MR.
COOPER CAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I MEAN JOINING IN
MEMORY OF MY CONSTITUENTS.
JEAN MARIE PHILLIPS OF LODI A
FOURTH GENERATION LEVINE G. WAS
MORE ON JUNE TWENTY SECOND.
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX THE PASSED
AWAY PEACEFULLY ON MAY FOURTH.
THE PHILS FAMILY ARE VERY WELL
KNOWN FOR THEIR GENEROSITY AND
GIVING BACK TO THEIR COMMUNITY.
JEAN ALWAYS WANTED A BIG FAMILY
SHE MARRIED LOVER LIFE DON
PHILLIPS IN NINETEEN FORTY SIX
AND REYES FIVE CHILDREN THERE
NINETEEN YEARS APART IN AGE.
GENDER LATE HUSBAND DON RUSSELL
CATHOLIC FOSTER PARENTS NOW FOR
THE HOME THE SEVERAL CHILDREN
OVER A TWENTY ONE YEAR PERIOD.
JIM WAS A PRIMARY FORCE FOR
CREATING THE BELOVED PUMPKIN
PATCH THAT PHILLIPS FARMS IN
LODI WHICH HAS BEEN OVER FORTY
YEARS HOSTING THOUSANDS OF
SCHOOL CHILDREN.
GEN ALSO MANAGE THE PHILS FARM
FRUIT STANDS WAS A PIONEER
STARTING THE FARMERS MARKET
MOVEMENT IN THE SEVENTIES.
JIM OF THE OUTDOORS AND TALLER
KIDS HUSKY FISH AND ENJOY THE
SIERRAS.
HE WAS ALSO KNOWN FOR AMAZING
COOKING HER LEGENDARY DILL
PICKLES.
JUST SURVIVE BY OUR SONS PETER
MICHAEL DAVID AND HER DAUGHTER
LAKHANI.
TOLD GRANDCHILDREN AND FIFTEEN
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER THANK
YOU MEMBERS.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUE.
SEEING HEARING OVER THE BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN.
MR RACING NEWS MISS MELENDEZ
SECONDS.
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY MAY SIXTEENTH AT
NINE AM.
WE ARE ADJOURNED
.
THE CHANGE MAYES AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT NO TO NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES SOME ABLE SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT NO IT'S NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE SHOULD MAYES EIGHTY
FIVE OH SIX I TO KNOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
SOME PEOPLE FIVE OF SIX I KNOW.
THE CHANGE GRAYSON.
AB TEN FOURTEEN I TO NOT VERY.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AS A NAVAL TEN FOURTEEN
I TO NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
RATHER